[Music]
oh my God
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
man you guys are giving me some giving
me a hard time there because
you're like man all those vendors are so
good but like what about the topic I
called Clinton a horrible person dude
I'm excited to see this
[Laughter]
happy to be here Clint thanks for
inviting me yeah absolutely
um you know Peter Ren you guys you know
you've been doing these a couple times
but Alan it is it's awesome to to have
you joined it's so so exciting to be
here I'm totally pumped I want to see
some amazing animation amazing art oh
it's and it's gonna be it's gonna be
um so guys thank you for your patience
we spent the last 15 minutes just trying
to like put out some some fire so
hopefully you can hear us
um right now so
yeah so all the way from orbit orbit
yeah look at how good Allen's uh green
screen key is isn't that amazing yeah
perfect right look at the absolute yeah
you know it's real
in a way it's real
only the best for the interns up there
in space I'm not allowed to back on
Earth so at least I can make it nice
around here in my workplace
you got that nice light from Pluto
blasting the side of your face too
that's very good that's right nice nice
radiation I'm only allowed to expose
myself for 10 minutes a day but it's
okay I'll do this multi-hour stream it's
fine it's not going to be healthy but
we'll get through it that's for sure
totally
um so guys here's what we're gonna get
into we got a hundred renders queued up
they're in DaVinci they're ready to go
um and we're gonna go through each one
give each one about a couple minutes
um and just talk about all the awesome
stuff that we love about it um we're
just gonna have a good time and hang out
and we have pre-selected the top five
okay
um but I'd like for you guys to guess
what you think your top five would be
um but we we got him pre we got them
pre-selected and we're gonna get through
all the all 100 and at the end we'll
announce the winners and there's a lot
of amazing prizes we got some uh
information in down in the description
but you know we got we got a lot a lot
of good stuff to give out today so
before we get into it before we dive in
um I want to shout out uh Rococo they
are sponsoring this stream
um so I'm gonna throw it real quick to
Rococo and we will be back in like a
minute and a half and we're gonna get in
to some amazing art I'll see you guys
soon
I don't know about you but for me the
most difficult part of the 3D process is
animation specifically character
animation now I find myself spending way
too much time tweaking stuff that nine
times out of ten just doesn't really
look right in the end and even the most
affordable motion capture suits can
still be pricey so Rococo the sponsor of
today's live stream they listened and
they put out a free no suit needed
motion capture solution called Rococo
video and it is by far the fastest way
to capture custom motion capture data
for free and bring it into your 3D scene
like I own one of their suits but
sometimes it's easier just to boot up my
webcam and capture some custom data they
make the process super simple through
their online portal where you just
upload your clip or capture it with a
webcam process it and clean things up in
their free software Rococo Studio it's
definitely a no-brainer tool to add to
the 3D tool belt so if you guys are also
having trouble with character animation
and don't have the means of throwing
down for a full on mocap suit definitely
check out Rococo video it's free there's
a link in the description go play around
with it it's super fun but for those of
you on the fence about getting a suit or
not Rococo has them back in stock no
more wait times and on top of that
they're offering you guys 10 off of any
of their suits by using the code Clint
10 that is
c-l-i-n-t-10 so go pick one up and have
some fun but hey thank you guys so much
for taking the time go show Rococo some
love by clicking that link down below
and let's hop in to these renders
that's why I was saying Rococo is my
favorite motion catcher suit by far
amazing yeah
too true too true
um guys it it is it's a time we have
five weeks it's been five weeks of hard
work from the whole Community we had
4200 renders we broke records with this
one oh my God yeah it's so many I think
the all renders video is gonna be like
seven hours or something it's it's
ridiculous oh my god
um I haven't housed with that sweet
sweet wash time yeah I hadn't tidied up
the total work hours but I had everyone
put in their work hours the last one we
did was 3 600 renders and it was 18
years of work I think or more oh my God
so this would probably be two decades at
least I'm excited
and that is why he was so mean and
strict with the rules and I just want to
say I'm on the side of the people here
I'm here to represent everybody that
didn't get in because of the
technicality people's champion
that's right I gotta draw the line
somewhere you know like people upload
full cuts of Transformers three it's
like I can't put that in
all right are you guys ready
absolutely
all right all right we're queued up
first render is popping off
um let's get a little switcher Rooney
and let it begin
hello classic I feel like I've seen this
you were watching this on Loop earlier
yeah
for a while this is Calvin Serrano
Calvin Serrano oh no kidding oh no okay
wait you do
that name sounds familiar should I know
Colin yeah wait uh this looks like a
Lego machine yeah it does it looks super
cool yeah that's dope love the colors
love the like it reminds me of like
so some Hot Wheels Saturday morning
cartoon I'm I'm doing yeah it's like
identical on the top it feels like one
of those machines that would run around
in like a Amazon warehouse I know Calvin
it's a comforting it doesn't matter
which way he'll land he'll be okay
exactly he's chilling on all sides it's
fun those particles
yeah good use of camera Shake
um really amps up the render I love the
the like classic orange blue color
contrast lighting is really nice and a
great sense of speed
honestly yes yes I forget which role
that is but it was yup the motion blur
is like not too much not not enough it
looks like you got proper motion blur on
that not enough
the tires look right because like I know
motion blown tires can be tricky but it
looks like they got it
and the sort of animation of the wheels
being loose then picking up speed again
it's been in like a good yeah that's
awesome
yeah simple background you know like
did a pretty good job um I know this is
tough because we see infinitely into the
background but you did a good job of
like bringing these buildings in kind of
close and having them go through an
Alleyway here towards the end so you
don't have to like build out multiple
cities in the background and everything
it's really well done yeah
um let me see if I can get the chat up
on the other screen
one moment guys
yes that is the schedule I missed the
render already
let me I'll get you guys get you guys in
a second
grabbing the corner of a window is so
scary because he might click something
and you're not trying to click
um Clint I gotta say this is grabbing a
corner on a Windows machine is scary
what's up friend
this render is awesome this little
wallpaper you got the render quality is
amazing oh dude I'm glad you enjoy it
here Chris a note everything yeah the
black is actually like black oh how
about that hey here's a little something
this is Osama oscari that's nice shout
outs to your boy
dude a nice little night render got some
rain in there and I'm hungry or BK yeah
there's lots of fireplacement in here
and for some reason yeah I don't know
why I could drink a Coca-Cola too I love
how when he slows down you can actually
see the suspension like absorbent yeah
and that's right it doesn't happen
yeah that's nice solid animation on this
one you can rip to that other person
the pursuer just gets wiped out in the
sewer
brutal yeah I love like the the wet
Reflections on the ground super nice
um like it looks like they're doing some
2D
2D particle stuff on the wheels or
something oh yeah totally
looks great but yeah super nice city
super fast
um intense motion
I keep thinking that says toilet up on
the side there me too
it says
apparently is British for
yeah is that what it is yeah that makes
sense that makes sense if it did say
toilet they would get a lot of traffic
you can't go wrong with a wet pavement
and some light glare absolutely it's
just like you're there
I can feel the sprinkles on my face
good stuff very good stuff Osama oscari
congratulations on top 100. all right
next up we have a name I can't pronounce
because it is in Chinese
it's like kanji or something hold on
oh got a little bit of a cross hatching
style whoa oh my God whoa
whoa oh my God that was interesting oh
yeah
so this is by taiji Ben at least on
Discord taiji Ben
I love that damn I'm loving this
animation style a story within a story
yeah yeah it's so good like the
the super like stuttery animation style
the snappiness of it yes
the 2D smoke coming out the back tire
right there that's beautiful dude this
guy is ripping he's going like 90 miles
an hour
I like how he has two different Wheels
one is like an Olympic racing wheel and
the front one is just like he bought it
at Goodwill
the front one is for uh you know for
steering and then the back one is for
power there you go oh
also I thought it was a GoPro at first
when uh it rack focuses to the camera
but I think that's it it looks more like
the the black magic like Cinema cameras
yeah that's like the studio camera yeah
yeah the little on a DJI like stabilizer
or something wait does the gimbal like
start for a moment it snaps yeah
dude I love the colors yeah and the
bouquet going like the out of focus you
could see like the five bladed Iris yeah
the main camera we're looking through is
using so you know it's high quality
that's a high quality lens
this one has no camera Shake one
it doesn't need it I know but it's crazy
it feels like it does it feels like it
has it but it doesn't those speed lines
yeah Grayson's in perspective here ah
man that green jacket like
something about the green and the purple
on the ground like the pink on the
ground
that's just um
I like this one yeah this one's super
sick super sick teji Ben sorry I cannot
pronounce that kanji but I see you on
Discord so congrats for that top 100.
next up we got
Sam huh
oh my Speeder Bike Tim Horton
oh that's great yeah this one's yes dude
those freaking Rockets
so good lots of going on yeah beautiful
on the side and then don't protect
himself
there's so much life in this
so are those Rockets are just like
normal
uh bullets both I don't know the
the the ship is so big that the normal
ship bullets are Rockets
I love the canvas on this little uh
speeder like it it's more than just like
a hard surface model it actually has
like some life and dynamics that are
reacting to the environment it also it's
uh spraying out little bits of air to
stabilize itself I just noticed that
yeah I just I want to know what he
catches in the little net in the front
honestly like I want to know the story
behind all of this watermelons it draws
me in watermelons
emotion colors
yeah this is very thought out and
there's like no
like inch of the of the screen that
isn't like populated with some kind of
Storytelling element yeah it leads your
eye perfectly
yeah this background looks like a fist
pointing up like this
yeah I could see it I can see it that's
awesome
I love the lighting in this one it's
really nice also the sky is really great
it gives the the feeling that it's some
sort of other planet because it's it has
a little bit of atmosphere but not that
much
Pluto this person's from Eastern Europe
you know that sign is like kind of like
a rude gesture in Eastern European
country so maybe that's what they're
going for with The Rock
dude that would be honestly Alan if that
wasn't the case that'd be next level
okay hi Galaxy brain level yeah
yeah this one's this one's super cool
super sick good stuff Sam congrats
um next up oh I freaking love this one
guys
it goes from adorable to awesome so
quickly it gives me a whiplash in my
heart
I want to watch this movie
yeah oh I just realized the dog in the
background like a little pug yeah yeah
pug boy those models are amazing I know
the character design here is amazing for
sure
stop the Chase and be like guys
you guys
that's one of the coolest like mask
add-ons I've ever seen too it's like oh
yeah it reminds me of a design for that
of Ratchet and Clank you guys remember
that game on PlayStation okay
I can see that yeah oh man I just love
the speed in this one the design of the
bike is so sick
um the tech is super cool it's very it's
very simple you know they didn't like
they have a background right but it's
not like
you can easily get overwhelmed by all
this Blank Space yeah
well look at those clouds those are at
least cards if not full 3d
State Road 22.
I don't know where that is
that 35 4 30.
artist aberrin
let's stop everything on Google which
state this could be
Highway 20. that's great yeah this one I
want that sword I like the limited
palette of it too there's something
funny about this sort of like dramatic
palette and these adorable creatures
it just sells it yeah agreed
yeah this one this one is definitely one
of my favorites I love it wait the sword
flips around when he grabs it it's now
backwards after he grabs it right really
what
put it in the IMDb Goofs
maybe it works out that way
this one's cool I love the character
design yeah yeah oh last thing last
thing I love you can see the lines in
the tire like the vertical lines in the
tire right there that's nice yeah ah
really really is nice all right all
right uh good stuff good stuff crew Bell
uh you're in you're in is next
oh Ghibli I love it gorgeous yeah
oh my goodness absolutely beautiful I
like how you can see like the vines
continuing to grow on the castle in the
background yes yeah there's some Vine
this guy did something bad in that
castle
yo he's got a plan Rick he stole a plan
oh that's what happens oh I see that the
little sapling yes it's the mom like
fighting
Mama plant is not happy I just thought
he stole the sacred logs
the Yule logs
or he chopped up some like resident
wheat plant creature that's that's dark
I guess does he have an iPad this is the
remnant yeah he does my little robot eye
patch he should not be flying that is a
safety concern
people managed to take the Ghibli style
and make it work across the entire
render like sometimes it's like just the
trees will be Ghibli style or like the
wood but this entire thing has such a
consistent art style looks amazing
yeah and it's not sure I like when it's
like it's not trying to be 2D to the
point of trying to fool you that it's
that style but it's not just a texture
it's not just a Shader thing it's
something like more intricate than that
so
props to this person to look yeah
you can delicate with it like look at
the the um propellers the lines yeah
yeah
it's just like an overlayer colors
themselves aren't motion blurred
but it does the exact same thing it
gives that sense of like uh you know
fast motion without having to get rid of
the detail of the propeller blade itself
it's so smart I love it
paying attention to like what would be
done and drawn in a hand-drawn situation
um staying within those limits
yeah you just you had just froze in it
and it like absolutely looks painted as
a still but like it absolutely doesn't
in motion it reminds me of like the
concept art you'd see at the end of
Mandalorian yeah totally yeah that's
true
beautiful good stuff you're in love it
you're insane
uh gallon is next
Golan Johnson
there's a lot happening here this is
this is high energy it's maxed yeah for
sure look at the animation that's
beautiful
the unfurling and the Michael Faye did
The Lego Movie
yeah right
right yeah it's it's nuts there's so
much going on
um
are these Transformers that looks like
maybe like an original like starscreen
type Transformer dude I just assume
anything that does this look yeah it's
just a Transformer it has to be it has
to be
um
that's gorgeous I love the animation
yeah it's really important
the little
having just enough time to engage the
Jets to take off weapons
are you am I okay yeah yeah technical
glitch I was just adoring how what was I
saying yeah how how there was just
enough it was just enough time for him
to engage his Thruster to as he becomes
the plane Do Not Crash and take it yeah
that's exciting
it's like he's done this before you know
like he's
he knows exactly them at a time at the
end he he's spinning into a plane but
then he's like one more and then playing
um Colin you did a really good job like
just filling out this chaotic scene this
war zone what what a ambitious thing to
tackle when you nailed it
very good stuff very very good stuff
congrats gone for you top 100 babies
next up who do we got
oh well this one oh yeah I've seen this
one
um
beautiful it makes me so scared
serious stuff is going down you
shouldn't be scared he's in a Ford
Jess Jesse perhaps oh I could no that's
not a this is like there's some insane
simulations going on here I have seen
this one online I'm pretty sure he used
Ember gen for the actual explosion but
that wouldn't solve the the actual
ground erupting like that I mean yeah so
much going on yeah you can see sorry
it's like the light from the explosion
underneath it letting it up that's
really nice wait what do you mean
holding underneath the rubble that's
that's coming up
dude this is ridiculous do you guys
think that the lack the no motion blur
is like an aesthetic decision
like I mean I could understand if a lot
of simulation and things don't give
enough time to to maybe render it that
way but maybe they did it on purpose
like I do feel like it sort of gives it
a different vibe like it would be too
disastrous and realistic is there yeah I
think it's uh like post 2D motion blur
and I I have a feeling they do that
because you can't render motion blur on
voxels
in a lot of programs like the foreground
things are totally crisp but like I I'm
saying it it feels like maybe it's a
choice
sure and it gives it that sort of like
it's definitely whipping it's whips
yeah it looks like it might just be like
something like real smart motion blur
applied on top yeah because the
foreground there on there would be
moving too fast for the Post filtering
to identify the motion at all whereas
like the background Towers have motion
blur because they're okay moving slow
enough
that makes sense I love the green and
orange colors here the color palette is
awesome yeah oh yeah makes me want to
like
apocalyptic
yeah it's the other clouds this is
beautiful current apocalyptic
wonderful stuff wonderful stuff uh meat
man these these names are getting harder
to pronounce
Jesse I apologize for that what if you
had to announce the Oscars this is how
you would approach the meaning there's
got to be like an SNL sketch like that
thousand of them that's too good
I thought those were eyeballs in the car
at first
I love that when it starts it's going so
insanely fast and then nope it's going
faster wait so it is the Jets are
destroying the the scenery no I think
there's like escaping the black hole
they're escaping the black hole okay I
like how you can see like trucks and
stuff flying up it looks like something
out of Twister or something you know
cool yeah yeah
super boost
yeah good thing this all the entries are
like a master class in in camera shake
their own little camera Shake style yeah
it's just right for it
dude that honestly the one um the guy on
the bike without camera shake that blew
my mind I didn't realize that didn't
have camera Shake because it really felt
like it and yeah I don't know why but
yeah I'm added to the drawing aesthetic
of it like sort of fusion aesthetic yeah
this one I love the Boost that it goes
into like the the freaking what do you
call like this the freaking lines at the
gas thrusters do it gets a little bit of
that going oh yeah I love that it's
almost like flicker or change shape at
all it just Remains the Same shape it
feels so powerful yeah and once once he
actually engages the Boost it's almost
like the shaking reduces to like give it
a sense of power like everything just
gets toned down because this thing is
really going it's like this the the
camera Shake syncs up with itself so it
doesn't it's like shaking so fast that
there's no camera Shake anymore yeah
oh it's larger scale camera shakes so at
first it's like small scale high
frequency and then it goes slightly
larger scale you're right dude these
details y'all these details love it so
good so good I am really happy I don't
live there yeah
yeah for sure don't settle next to a
black hole it's just common sense
foreign
[Music]
it's just the guy's just looking what is
this guy chasing oh that's scary well
it's definitely it right you got the
balloon tied to the uh yeah yeah
agreed the lighting is great color's
great mm-hmm
and you're actually
actually water splashes like the the
splashing up off of the water that's
really nice
the droplets yeah keeper
oh my God yeah oh look at this the the
water like rushing over little bits in
the curb you see that like
running yeah yeah it's pretty nice
wow yeah this one's sick that's
beautiful
yeah big fan biku yeah
good stuff good stuff congrats top 100
baby all right who's next
sub d1v
those are sunflowers
very good
scoop whoa
chickens look at the chickens in the
thing save our stolen albanians
what do you say Alan
like silver that that toy line sylvanian
families is that what it's called these
little cute creatures it feels like
those toys like uh started maxed out
having a crisis yeah those chickens in
there are so freaking cute so here's
here's the question are they
stealing the chickens or saving the
chicken oh yeah oh my God I guess
chicken eyes
are so happy
yeah yeah he's like what is the story I
guess
they're being stolen I don't know
like it's a cat so a cat would be
healing them no here's the thing here's
the thing here's the thing the cat owns
the farm
because obviously it's skilled at using
the the Machinery right so
um something happened and they're like
guys we gotta go
uh yeah so the cat's running from
something we're going this is just an
empty building now
we don't live here
yeah this one's awesome so the motion
blur is kind of confusing me a little
bit look at the motion blur at the stuff
that he hits on the right of frame okay
uh oh it's Global motion blur so it's
it's not motion blur in relation to the
camera it's in relation to the world to
the uh oh so maybe the shake was to an
afterthought
Maybe
see the wheels too it's tough
I like how unfazed the cat is with all
this
we're doing this yeah the chickens are
not as cool headed like there's like you
know the cat's doing his thing and then
there's like maybe he furrows his brow
right there but I can't tell oh there's
a blanket
I love the aesthetic here there's like a
like a yeah like a plastic toy aesthetic
to the whole thing yeah almost like a
Wallace and grommet type yeah totally
big fan big fan good stuff
uh oh man buckle up Donald Cela
oh no dude
[Music]
that's amazing do those Rockets coming
in from the distance the missiles from
the yeah I want to watch this movie
dude this is so sick
look at the guys what's up the guy the
guy in the back the bad guy in the oh
yeah the mothership oh my God
yeah he's like I'm Coming For You Baby
like he this this explosion will not
phase him you'll never get away
I love this explosion everything from
the fire to the debris like all of it is
the Ripple like slowly it ripples out it
gives it a sense of power that like a
fast motion explosion wouldn't quite do
it gives it a sense of scale oh yeah
everything is and the robot the robot is
has a sense of scale even though with
all this speed like there's such a
feeling of weight to it
weight and like how slippery that deck
is and everything it's like
it makes me feel like you know it's a
Boston Dynamic robot yeah trying to keep
balance so it's a little hard to see but
there's like a guy in the cockpit yeah
oh yeah like getting into the cockpits
it's a baby man it's a little child a
woman is it he
just got a ponytail oh somebody's got a
pointy tip the dude's got ponytails
there
yeah I mean let's not assume
the fire composite is incredible by the
way yes yeah fire looks good
this was also in that ember gen trailer
at the end oh really okay yeah okay oh
dang okay
yeah that's some beautiful fire I should
download amberjack this one gets too
honestly you should it's really great
yeah this one's sick this one's amazing
um good stuff Donald a little yeah keep
going Allen element just like keeps you
I was just gonna say like the one like
green interface in the in the cockpit is
like it kind of draws your eye in there
yeah because it's it's a lot of things
going on but you notice the character
because of that yeah love it love it
beautiful and the ship like the ship in
the background look at the little like
little shrimp yeah the shrimp legs
it's not a crawfish it's a crush it
so cool so cool ah amazing uh Peter
pioter dismas
oh so this this is another one of those
with the that crosshatch style is it
cross hatch is that the right word for
it dude that's a big hat like a a screen
print oh no wait what's the word uh uh
like the dot printing on Comics yeah
yeah yeah is that stippled uh uh
stippled soundtrack
there's four of us here we can't think
of the simple term that everybody's
screaming at us
this one feels like a commercial to me
like screen tones it's a screen screen
tones that's what it's applied on oh
okay cool cool
um cool yeah I like the hippie Vibe of
this it's like it's almost like a cut
out animation like classic sort of black
cutout stuff yeah yeah it almost looks
like there's an aspect of like puppet
tool going on with this character
yeah
ladies they're even
I don't even know if it was done in 3D
like frankly like who knows sort of
yeah
all right in the background I love their
colors and everything is just so vibrant
and like this is so far out of all of
them this is the one that just feels
like the most like a commercial or
something I don't I don't know for what
yeah yeah this is beautiful
dude that I just realized that exhaust
pipe is like a freaking curlicue and
it's
Dr Seuss energy yeah this thing yeah
amazing I love this one so mushrooms
trying to find any like little hidden
hidden secrets
uh their design language is real
consistent throughout all this yeah
super nice yeah the sense of scale is
not here tiny truck big shrooms
that's my life when I was a kid I had
this like little children's book that
was like a story about a couple of mice
like messing with a cat but it was all
Illustrated in this very strange style
of like everything was dim and like that
sort of orangey hazy desert Sunset style
and there's like these Roman column
remnants like for some reason in this
little children's thing and this gives
me like a little bit of that Vibe that's
crazy it's took you back in kids book
man wow yeah I think I have it somewhere
I have to dig it up dude look who's
driving yeah this gives me that that
feeling like it's fun but it's not that
fun there's a little bit of like
Darkness to it yeah
enticing puppy driving the car oh
a truck for dogs
down yep good stuff pioter Peter dismas
um this one let's see who's this
this is
it's so fun how this car is almost
falling apart dark I love how each
little bed is moving separately that's
beautiful Ren how you doing
oh what's wrong buddy I don't like
spiders but this is cool this is like
the rimmer quality this is high level
this is yeah what is that little thing
is the driver a spider too no that's
something remember is a bug is a spider
some sort of little creature look at
this little spider leg okay look at the
spiders some sort of dude he's got a 3D
Vision for sure he's got the little uh
anaglic Vision dude
what there's a skull jumping over us
like a mouse
that's intense this reminds me of a
little big planet
oh yeah yeah it's got like Little Big
Planet Vibes also like the color palette
goes that way too there's a box it has a
box in the front seat
Chopper chop
look at that what'd you just call me
whoa hey bud hey bud hey bud
like from not necessarily visually
aesthetically but it's like feels like
from the world of that uh blender open
movie short with the mushrooms killing
everyone like it's that kind of cool
Forest world that's what that's what
this is did you guys see that
see that spider that's on frame for like
quarter second at the top no no like
under the tunnel under the tunnel
because there's two right the big
there's yeah there's the big ones and
then right here there's that third one
there oh god oh that's awesome oh only
somebody who's scared of spiders would
notice that
oh
that's disgusting oh this raises a lot
of questions I just want to know more
exactly that's what this is
love the design four random leaves
Route 66
and I want to watch this movie
let's go boys
this fox doesn't have a neck it's just I
want to know what what is the camera
vehicle is it like is it a Russian arm
like what are we what is this thing I
want to see the camera car yeah I think
it's one of those uh yeah is that what
that's called Russian arm yeah coming
over like The Swinging arm yeah I like
how we can actually see that camera's
POV on the viewfinder of it yeah oh
really oh for real
oh cool yeah
um let's see well first off I think you
can control because it comes to such a
perfect stop sure sure you can see his
name for a brief moment on his jacket
what is this expression is so funny
in the name wait company move a frame
back gerpy Dipper oh yeah no sorry that
was
another example of what the letters yeah
yeah definitely um it's pretty good
though the building
and the buildings are like facades for
uh oh my God yeah that's so fun oh
you're right yeah this is so good
beppany his name's beppany unless that's
another language
yeah and then like the POV is cool
why oh yeah so the the driver is like a
little life thing robot
yeah
he's monitoring his own heartbeat I
guess it's just like I am alone
like in this world the stunt drivers are
little robots so it's a stunned
performer
um for the scene
I'll be responsible that dude is just
firing his gun off into the air
I like the texturing on the car
yeah it smells it's got a little bit of
that like oh yeah upper uh the tape
coming off a little uh substance painter
number
dude look at his little stubby foot on
the window it's so funny
it's a little shoe
yeah oh my God I wish I want to see like
little uh safety harness connecting him
to the car I know I know good point good
stuff though this is uh kakuto
show me zoo yeah amazing congratulations
on top 100.
um Patrick is next
Patrick salane oh my god oh wow it's got
all these characters stealing precious
items from things
this is amazing
I thought that was Patrick from
SpongeBob at first dude
if he fell into a nuclear reactor
yeah
this is the guys in the back look like
the those germs they showed Mr Burns
like why he's not sick like all the
germs can't get through the door little
toy germs that's what those guys well
guys remind me of in SpongeBob did you
know that Bikini Bottom is based on a
real place in the world where they did
nuclear testing and that's why all the
are you friends sea creatures are all
messed up yeah yeah
that's insane
this is beautiful though and the
animation is so so perfect there's a
good sense of Parallax with the
background too like there's various
levels of things moving so you get solid
motion also the lighting and the colors
yeah I've never been to Brazil but I
imagine this is what Brazil like feels
like you know sunny and like different
like the pie stealing Jewels all over
the place I think that's what it's like
oh it's great yeah I love the animation
of the crowd too going over the jump is
awesome yeah I wonder if they animated
all those individually
so
maybe it's like a walk cycle and then
I'm wondering for the rendering on these
guys is there like am I seeing some
subsurface scattering type stuff like a
bit of like a waxy type render can you
pause it right on the dude who's like
floating up towards the motorcycle
but yeah a little bit yeah a little butt
it looks great it seems that way
oh yeah this really it has a bunch of
surface detail too yeah it's nice
beautiful
it's like a little putty oh my God
there's like a facial animation of this
dude he's like
a toy from the early 2000s yeah it's
like one of those things that stick to a
wall and like fall down
um it the motion blur feels like very
directed like there's it's there's a lot
of it where you need it and a little bit
of it where you don't where they want to
see like the character's face and stuff
that's how it seems interesting that's a
good point
that's high level if they're if they're
doing that that's certainly some high
level
art Direction dream is motion blur talk
[Music]
I like how he comes close to the camera
there at the end it's like yeah yeah
good transition good stuff Patrick
congrats
sunset
whoa whoa whoa whoa
[Music]
I would play this game
oh he drops the dynamite he's like
oh wait what's the what is it's like an
evil hand yes it's a demon hand trying
to grab him what is going on in this
cave oh there's like a thing you see its
eyes yeah it's an evil cave oh yeah okay
it's the whole monster
oh yeah
oh that is a Campbell's Soup can isn't
it
this is like
Chippendale Rescue Rangers style device
making Vehicles out of stuff
so he like looks at the eyes he looks at
the hand
oh that's his eyes are literally just
scribbles of white that's so cool
this reminds me of a Mario Kart level
oh damn that is sweet yeah very cool
blend of 2D
um effects yeah agreed uh
shooting shooting Liu
is this
this video has great pacing like I love
the timing and the feel of the explosion
and the fall from that it's like this
works really well then coming out to
that epic Sunset yeah yeah good victory
it's nice yeah but agreed Alan the mix
of 2D and 3D is really nice on this one
his hats of like a bell yeah a little
Miner's cap adorable also notice how the
headlight turns off when the explosion
goes on
or oh when it explodes and then it comes
back on after he lands yeah that's cool
yeah this one's cool I'll take this one
the little Christmas lights
nice congrats shoot shoot shooting you
man
apologies y'all apologies on these names
apologies
uh this is Victor
oh cool we're gonna get a copyright
[Applause]
okay oh my God
hands down my favorite Flintstones
render yeah there was like four
Flintstones renders this was my favorite
that's so great yeah it's fun the
animation
this feels like something that would
happen
on The Flintstones yeah a second look at
those mountains yeah the colors man
beautiful
nice motion blur really solid
the the gardeners are starting in my uh
yard let me know if it gets loud okay
sounds good
yeah this one's this one's sick I love
the colors the animation
um those are the big ones for me of
course render quality too you know and
lighting and stuff but yeah
beautiful yeah
good stuff this looks like it could
actually be a Flintstones movie like
this style could totally carry a
Flintstones movie 100 dude yeah I can
see that 100 good stuff Victor congrats
top 100
who's next who's next
also shout out to all of the Great Clips
facial animations these are all the top
100 I didn't catch that
wait what really
I'm just kidding I was just confirming
are these 100 yes yes this is so rad
yeah dude
like over a bump it like okay so the guy
sits down they go for a bump and then it
jumps them back up and so he's like I'm
just gonna dance
like I'm going with it I meant to do
that go this is absolutely amazing
this is the first one that's like very
explicitly stop motion imitating and
it's like that Rudolph the Red-Nosed
Reindeer old school very economical
stop-motion yeah
oh yeah
yeah
they're not like evading a threat or
anything they're just vibing
yeah yeah so every two frames in the
background it's doing that Spiderman
thing the background the background
but the foreground is on tools and you
see that represents that they're
learning to be mushrooms
oh this is every frame now that's cool
oh my God that's amazing look at the
books they pop in there oh fun why does
it look like the Pringles are they are
they book vendors
dude look at the guy on the right
Library
he's like whoever made this can you
please make it a future length movie
yeah send it to me
in their world yeah mushrooms are people
and trees because we're all living
creatures wow deep and that's kind of
the world yeah Max congrats to you
amazing amazing work very good stuff
super cool
I like the texture on the waterfall too
yeah nice very nice
uh Andre
well
get ready for the Boost
that's nice
feel the impact yeah
yeah good wow The Selective camera do
you think that's hand animated like just
the weight of it or there's some kind of
simulation well obviously for the part
for the the bricks but like
mated yeah I don't I don't know I love
all the zombies you can just see in the
background like you can't really see
them individually but you can clearly
make out their Silhouettes so enough to
know that this is a sketchy territory
yeah like right at the end too all the
horde back there just they're they're
lighting and their render quality is
ridiculous and the Sim of course is just
yeah this one's great this whole thing
is beautiful this looks like The Walking
Dead cinematic you know like
also I've never seen like a semi truck
pulling a
trailer type thing before that's cool
super cool like uh Survivor little
Loadout that this guy's got going on I'm
sticking with these guys if I'm like in
this world yeah totally they seem to
have it figured out the subdued colors
are great I love the like kind of green
yellow
vibes
yeah
the lighting too on the trailer
yeah that's
that's the touch there it's like would
you need those lights in real
render looks so so better yeah
yeah that's really nice yeah good stuff
Andre congrats to you man I can't wait
to place all of these in their very
specific spots in the actual like
Montage with the custom music because my
buddy Casey he's doing all this custom
music and it's it's gonna be it's gonna
be beefy they're all going to be woven
into a continuous story you're saying
they'll be woven into a continuous video
but yeah
not in order of how good they are
anyway
this is by Billy gurge
yeah
wait is this car changing colors or is
that just the lighting on it the
lighting I guess I think it's the
lighting yeah okay yeah
yeah that's an accurate NSX in the
background catching up
wait Wren you know you know car stuff a
little bit I drove that one in there so
cool really the that purple one yeah it
looks I mean maybe some other car I
don't know but I like that that metallic
look to it yeah this is such a good job
of like that city at night
um kind of style like a lot of people
did that a lot of people went for the
city at night and I think um it's tough
to like kind of Stand Out Among the most
popular renders you know
um like it's nice doing a low poly thing
but a like high quality
cheating
on the cars they have like the wheels
tilted inward I don't know what that's
called but that when you tilt the wheels
inward a little bit for like car
like for car stuff yeah
for that traction oh
yes yes
um some people go ham with it though
it's like whoa dude yeah what does that
license plate say Guernsey gurge this is
like his name
yeah Billy good stuff man love the
motion blur love the animation super
super intense congrats super super
awesome uh the next one
I love this one guys oh whoa damn just
magic
that's fun yeah I'm a cartoon guy cool
the Lego guy you can see like the lines
and stuff that hold it up yeah like this
is based in reality because this is what
like a kid with with a lot of cinematic
ambition would shoot this kind of thing
like in real time yeah
wait did something drop there love the
light left right on the left yeah what's
the plan
what is it is it the frame rate what is
it no it's like the wings cut something
no no there's the airplane yeah yeah is
there anything on the stick okay
yeah I love the lighting
the little thumb the little thumb tacks
holding up the dragon legs
what oh my God yeah little pins and um
I just love the like the lighting here
is they really nailed the like magical
feeling in their bedroom with like the
little Starlight thing and yeah it's so
cool
oh love this one super nice uh
is their name
um next up we have A's
whoa whoa dragonflies I love them big
dude I want to be a dragonfly yo there's
a guy
insect it's like a guy with that thing
he's like yo got the Skyrim helmet it's
a Skyrim guy yeah yeah oh bug
before
yeah he does yeah
yeah dude that would have been an
expensive fix for that
this is amazing yeah yeah all the
foliage yeah it reminds me of uh when I
was a kid I'd play army men air attack
or army men like Sarge's Heroes you know
you guys remember those army army games
on PlayStation one
truly
yeah yeah dude those games you fight
bugs like you're like little helicopter
toys and you fight bugs and stuff maybe
that's what this is
it very well could be it's a Toy Story
situation because they're not like
unlike the previous thing they're not
being operated but they're clearly toys
yeah and so they're just alive so that's
this world let's be clear whoa I just
realized the bullets he's shooting are
getting disrupted
by the dragonflies wings
[Music]
that's cool yeah yeah
so sick yeah I love this one like super
low to the ground feeling all the little
like weeds whip by and everything it's
super cool
yeah it's fun A's A's mokton yeah the
way that the bottom the grass on the
ground is like just coming in and out of
that very shallow Focus just so fun to
stare at air speed is is really nice
very good stuff congrats
next up we got
valve I think
oh whoa whoa
yeah that is awesome
wait where did the Cat come from oh he
was there the whole time he's just
deciding to chase it like all cats oh
this is great yeah
love this the slow-mo is awesome at the
end
car's going Wiley
now that that end the the glitching at
the end is part of it right like it's so
adorable
or is it just a bad encoding I don't
know I think no it's I think it's a da
Vinci thing it's like all of the renders
do that if you look closely I think he
breaks the camera at the end that's what
it is I choose to believe
yeah all the dust particles on the table
top is really nice helps with the speed
yeah yeah
that's a chunky Cat by the way
and that that Pro you you see like very
little detail of him running but that
probably took a lot of work to get that
that animal motion yeah and I like how
he knocks the trophy too not easy oh
that's cool
yeah I dig this yeah this one has a
great setup and delivery because you see
the cat because our eyes are tuned for
that type of danger like and I found
myself wanting to see and then he
delivers at the end of the shot you
clearly see the cat filling the whole
frame it's like yes yeah it's really
nice
good setup good payoff
good stuff fav
uh
Jamie is next
whoa
[Music]
dude a freaking sports card body on that
monster truck that's awesome there's
suspension that like animation on their
rig is ridiculous yeah it looks great
crazy rig and they're they're like like
you just want to be on it yes
the smoke is great it is I know and the
lighting yeah beautiful the backlight
Great Smoke rendering mm-hmm
yeah this one's beautiful
Star Wars kind of
architecture totally yo Peter I think it
got a little quiet
oh sorry yeah there was a leaf blower I
didn't want to oh and here comes
he comes into your background use your
operatic voice into your house
that's true
here I'll just do this is that better
that's perfect dude is it like the way
that the character behaves
it makes me feel like this is a toy
world as well something about the person
feels like
a toy aesthetic yeah because they're so
small like on the this giant vehicle I
want to know what he's shooting at
he seems to not care it's like I don't
know
I know dude the smoke is so beautiful
with the backlight oh yeah
really nice good stuff Jamie I can't not
say it that way I'm sorry
um
is next
and engage yeah yeah that's full 360. oh
the animation is so clean I know
yeah
and it feels like a plausible maneuver
like as crazy as it is like I I buy her
getting back up without a leg though
momentum of it
like road rash on that leg you just you
would oh
the headlights yeah I was about to say
the headlight goes down when the powers
activate no that's cool that's cool
didn't realize that
I think my favorite thing is just how
that little robot just gets owned so
hard and smack and it's out of the game
this one you really want to hear the
sound design of it yeah that crunch
um
yeah a lot of people did sound design uh
with their renders and we we don't judge
with the sound design we turn it off and
of course for the Montage this off but
like you know all you guys uploading
your own renders and showing your
breakdowns of course all your sound your
beautiful sound design is included but
um yeah I wish I could include it all
but
yeah these are I can imagine it the
visual sells it alone yeah so good good
stuff Zang amazing I love the evolution
of color you know it starts off with the
the red and the warm ends with the blue
yeah oh that's cool yeah
oh just so smooth I want to pull that
move on The Daily
let's do a spin move man yeah
who's next honest I want to see that
counter steering though oh man
whoa dude share what are these chariots
what they're like little pups
I kind of love it look at the the the
treads on the back of those things
oh sorry who lost it I was making
adjustments
no
spoilers get it together too early oh
sorry Peter sorry that's
there's no creatures inside the the
building vehicles I think so I think
it's just it's just engines okay
cool a hang glide situation yeah an
interesting style I like it
yeah whoa It's randomly in the
background like oh my God it's snowing
it is snowing it's a fun just a fun
situation yeah a lot of questions I am
fascinated by these machines
yeah I want one of these
right dude it takes me a long time to
make sense of this world if I like crash
landed here
yeah really nice love the the color
palette for sure and like I love the
snow mixed with the desert it's Unique
for sure it's just a good old time hang
gliding with your little Robo Bros you
know it feels like the these machines
these polar machines are like they have
a mind of their own and they're just
happy to hop around and you've got to
like deal with that yeah like okay all
right settle down just like pulling
forward here guys yeah I'm still
seriously so like confused about what
the background mountain is telling us
like is is this a monument to the bio
biological origins of this story like
why is there a giant hippo Mountain no
this is my maybe like uh
long after organic life forms have
stopped existing on this world it's a
monument to something that was once was
Wren that's what it is good stuff wire
Soul shout outs to wire Soul uh we got
Paul
next
fall
wow that's gorgeous yeah of course
thrusters activate it's a beautiful
model OKAY thrusters I know the render
qualities heartwarming staple
sci-fi since 1985 at 1989. is that
Shanghai is that is the background
Shanghai it is yeah or well is it is it
because uh because uh the Germany
there's a tower like that with the ball
oh in Munich or something too oh well I
couldn't tell you then
not sure yeah Beauty absolutely
beautiful though beautiful like this one
has a certain feeling to it like a
cinematic quality to it that a lot like
someone like a lot of these do in top
100 of course but they're they're
knocking it out they got I think some
film green on here I think is their
color correction and just right okay
they're like sharp highlights cohesive
yeah
very Punchy and the animation is smooth
and consistent you know it's like I
don't have any notes on the animation
agreed yeah there's some Perfections on
the side of the car oh dude that thing
is doing good I think we've determined
he's doing a maneuver that it would be
difficult to do on Wheels on the
slippery Road and that is why this is
happening yeah because we're like why do
they have to fly you know it was the
question
I think like I think I buy it you know
what the heck out of there if they were
on the ground
for the first time I didn't notice the
the driver before but yeah it's just
like a dude it's like the kind of dude
you would expect to do this you can make
some Mojo kind of guy Paul Walker
it kind of looks like Paul Walker
actually
just so casual just like
just like I am good stuff good stuff
Paul love it
uh next up we got our boy you know
evolution
hmm
this is awesome a lot of stuff going
down outside
yeah probably best to get out of there
oh 30405 so cool
yeah I just love the this one is also
very filmic to me it has definitely has
the the film Grain on it I don't know
like YouTube compression is probably
killing it but
um
yeah there's some film grain in here it
looks really nice and the Escape is so
cool it's a two-part kind of a two-part
deal
I love it yeah yeah I love how like it's
it's very dedicated to that blue purple
uh red sort of aesthetic at the very
beginning and then suddenly in space
yeah like you wouldn't expect that at
the beginning that's not the the typical
inside of a spaceship so it kind of just
like throws you for a loop in a pleasant
way yeah it's a good one too for sure
that's like that's that's one of the
biggest things with pulling the top 100
is like we really tried to find renders
that weren't just like
static you know it's like you sit there
and then you go away it's like what's
happening in between what's the story
what's the midpoint shift you know
um this one does such a good job of it
it's got a little radar dish on top of
it it's just more yeah like suspicious
this drone is out for himself or I guess
it is a it's a it's a ship right there's
little windows
there's humans in there yeah
dig it good stuff Lino congrats
we got who oh what oh
guys
wait is this concerning
your arms yeah arms are scaring me
that's crazy this is by Robert kautz um
goes by Edge on our server and he always
knocks the ball out of the park
this is nuts I love how you can see all
the gov in the reflection of the glass
oh I didn't even realize that yeah you
just had to like model all those things
out there
just for that
God this looks like a very strong
machine yeah
awesome part of it like an awesome short
film too
yeah the like like it's weathered man I
think it's been through some service bot
for sure I guess but like
um the Salvage mission of some sort yeah
exploring I think they're rescuing
someone wait that's a person in there in
the on his back yeah everyone else is
dead
where
all those pods are people back oh
they're rescuing a pot okay I got you
it's like a
like a destroyed suspension suspended
animation pod how the thing it lands on
like it's ever so slightly it's a
nice detail this uh the aesthetic here
reminds me of the beginning of the force
awakens when she's like going through
that ship it's got like that right that
same amount of Bloom
um yeah the light leaking into the ship
through cracks and stuff
so good yeah I love this design or
not the ship but like this little
creature ship thing the machine it looks
like something you'd put in a hydraulic
press and it doesn't break yeah yeah it
looks powerful
this is incredible and very functional
yes there's no nonsense there's no fun
things it's just for pure function
good stuff good stuff yeah
oh at first I thought he was just like
throwing away uh a pod with a person in
it because it was dead already but I
think it was just like the door of a pod
oh man
[Music]
okay
God that's okay there's a lot Happening
Here David milore
mograph very playable game the colors
are just massaging my brain
you know it it feels so good to look at
this yeah I just wanna play with these
toys and
go back to being a kid I know I know
very stimulating
speaking of eating things this also
perfectly Loops oh wait what hold on
oh my God that's right perfectly that's
right
this this stippling oh the green tones
yeah they're there too
very cool it hits a little guy like what
is it it's a
major blending of all these Styles like
this one's more Unapologetic mixed media
that's fun yeah that's so cute and then
the little Donuts coming out the back
the little the donuts
so is this a Donut bakery on wheels or
is it a delivery truck
I hope both
yeah this one's sick the color is the
animation the texture the render quality
this like I guess maybe story
you know it's got that little there's so
yeah
yeah you watch this movie in a heartbeat
no doubt No Doubt
stuff David malore that's awesome
congrats man congrats uh pic Clint on
one of these streams you gotta have like
a Sony producer or something just
hanging out being like okay yeah this
person can call me and you know the
award is just a Pixar sale in the room
whoa what the whoa what the whoa
dude the guy with the cigarette it's
like 400 pounds that's great
is he trying to be like I'm confused
yeah it's a Batman kill
that just barely squeezed onto his head
these characters are just kind of like
fans of the the superheroes and they're
just kind of styling themselves vaguely
as that like that's what I get like yeah
yeah you know bad guy Batman whatever
I'm one of those guys it's like they
were at a they were at Comic Con and
they were like hey let's get into some
trouble
Harley Queen they took it
it's funny yeah this one's fun love the
animation the textures the quality
lighting and color really nice this is
uh yeah wait go I want can we see the
the explosion yes by frame it's really
doing like an anime like platforms fun
like oh it looking inverted frame yeah I
love that I didn't even note geez I
didn't even notice that
yeah I'm doing that in my game when you
hit an enemy they invert for a second
and it really helps solve the impact
right here it really gives it that snap
that's a good idea that's a good idea
nice good stuff
uh we are still you're still really
quiet Peter
gotta hold that mic close whoa dude
whoa the background's flipping up
there's coins
oh it's the opposite of what normally
happens with coins I normally you get
them hooping them out yeah this one's
crazy the colors are ridiculous I love
the visceral animation the flip at the
end like the world curving up in the
back is so cool I have no idea what's
happening though
I like to think that he's he's like
spending his coins he's like in line at
the the car shop and he's like spinning
the coins and then he's the upgrade that
makes sense exactly this is what it is
yeah
and it's all set in like they got a new
architect and an Inception dreams
they prefer limited palette like this
and that's why this looks like this
fine beautiful that's great guys better
should I turn up the game anymore oh
you're good you sound good to me yeah
yeah that's nice yeah
um yeah the colors on this one I think
it could have been cool to have like
another another uh car on the track
somewhere because it's definitely like a
race you know some sort of some sort of
race I guess like maybe when it curves
up it's just so far ahead it doesn't
matter that's a good point
that's a good point the animation is
great
um yeah totally it's fun I feel very
confident oh that's what it is something
about it yeah
yeah good stuff this is Guam
Guillaume with me
so sorry
the second car lands it's just like so
fun yeah
we got Ben
whoa Lego boy oh straight up this is
Lego Movie
dude like someone's being a wheel
yeah I literally think this happened
from the movie yeah okay I am the wheel
that's so great
this is absurd little pig on there it's
great oh so fun yeah render quality
animation just wackiness uh
since it's maxed out so good oh my God
and even the smoke from the tires is
Legos yeah yeah I was about to say
they're doing the whole voxelized
smokesen thing too so cool man what a
great job
it's a true it's like true to
a like a Lego a Lego thing they're not
they're not they don't need to do
anything extra what about the lasers
though hold on are they pieces because I
know they got glowy pieces they that's
the same way they did them in the movie
really it's like little glowy pieces
yeah wait what are those bricks flying
out rocks breaking off the back of the
car that damage yeah awesome cool or
maybe it's just it's just the wheel
so yeah they're the actual little
cylinders and then like that weed piece
that's the muzzle flash yeah
that's so sick
yeah okay it's popped in the head right
there that's awesome yeah good stuff Ben
really really fun scene
gear World whoa
whoa whoa oh cool yeah I like the design
of this see if they redid the game like
this I know I know I would I would I
would play this for sure because it's
like the classic shape and it even is
like the low poly shape but with a
modern detailing it looks super nice
yeah is there a specific game this is
inspired by it reminds me what's that
one game it's like wipeout or something
oh no Wipeout I know what you're talking
about I love that game this is
definitely Star Fox
um but okay there's some Wipeout renders
uh people some people didn't wipe out
renders
but yeah I love this like the Simplicity
you know
they need to skip the couple of frames
at the end so that the pillars Loop
nicely it's like
those couple of frames
oh yeah
so the background work is amazing this
is a Star Fox thing shouldn't he do a
barrel roll you know what yeah you're so
right and that's the that's the problem
is you're right dude
dude I saw a bird do a barrel roll the
other day
huh that's incredible story is much more
interesting than what I was gonna say I
was I was at a stoplight and I look up
and I see this bird dive and it like put
its wings like this and then it did a
barrel roll and then like like did a
like a hard turn out of the barrel roll
that's so sick it was amazing yeah wow
okay so what kind of bird was it it was
like was it a pigeon
okay cool yeah I was just gonna say that
as a person who's not influenced by
knowing about any games ever I don't
think anything needs to do a barrel roll
and I like it just fine so whoever made
this just know that I think it's cool
hey there you go dark style I like the
the Skybox the planet the the clouds
yeah it's really nice underboomer coming
in
yeah big fan big fan that's gerwald
Gerald Jerry yelled congratulations
who's next
our boy Carson Lee
whoa dude with the blades this has been
the same universe as the dogs with the
swords I could see it right 100 this is
Metropolis like
like the main city level of that game
yeah
damn that's sick yeah super cool like
one of the few renders to do
rollerblades and have someone like
sliding around like that is super cool
this is what I felt like when I was a
kid and I was rollerblading dude this
cat looks so confused he's like
cross-eyed
like oh I did not expect that loss of
balance it's like really focused on his
control panel like right here
and the spherical companion satellite
creature exists throughout all the
universes like there's always that guy
it's an eternal
also there are so many means of thrust
on this thing
it's boosted out to the max
yeah I'm trying to see what the the text
on all the signs are
Burger bunny
cyber cyber bunny bunny Crypt oh no does
that say Crypto Crypt something yeah
Crypt Keeper probably I know let's
assume the Cyber bunny
who's that funny
or a cat I think it was a cat
looks like a cat yeah oh my god when you
pause on it it could be like a little
he's almost maybe he's a little raccoon
or something in a very stylized way
but yeah I guess cats yeah they're
definitely stressed out they're like I
don't know how to control those things
but oh he closes his windows take
oh there's that
he's using the same technique as that
robot with the net ship yes to close the
window technique
it's a good one you'll save your life
good stuff Carson
Farren is next oh
[Music]
my god dude wow that is very like 80s
anime
and it almost loops
specific time period yeah animation yeah
dude they smeared some of the frames for
motion blur oh yeah let's see that bus
in the foreground yes at the beginning
of the van
I love how he comes into frame backwards
that's genius yeah those smears it's
just painted on that's amazing it works
so well though this is where like this
this isn't the era when you would hand
paint a cell and the art the painter I
guess just has the instruction of just
like just add smears to past the lines
yeah are things on twos but it's all out
of sync
yeah that's a little it's a little weird
something happening every frame
and I think that's to maybe perhaps get
around the the 12 FPS look while still
having that sort of like jittery sort of
animated feel dude look how excited he
is look how sure he is
they're doing a lot of hand painting on
these too
makes me wonder like how much of this is
CG versus you know straight up painted
on top
that's awesome yeah definitely the
smears
the colors they chose are like perfect
yeah
yeah that dark blue sky is so
reminiscent of the time yeah they have
the look of like it's been on analog
tape you have beta tape and it's been
shown it's been transferred from Hal to
ntsc
this one's yeah this one's super fun
same same
so good uh that's by farron congrats
Faron really good stuff
guy is next
guy Collins oh yeah
is that a loop it looks like it I don't
know
not a Pineapple Bomb yes a pineapple
grenade
hard work more dessert
yeah this is awesome
wait say that again red what was that
t-pose clothes I'm reading the signs in
the background
controls here too
yeah let's take a look it's like warbly
wait there's messages in the sky hashtag
visual weight
oh whoa yeah it's back there I don't
know if this is referencing a specific
thing yeah
unless you're gonna say something else
so sorry I was just saying like I don't
know I don't it just feels like that
sort of quintessential
internet animation style like just like
the good animators online in the early
2000s like that's how it feels totally
to me
absolutely driver has such good aim she
shoots his glasses off with him pointed
away from her
shot dude she's really looking down
those iron sights
look at look at her with the tongue out
she's like I got this
yeah such great details in the like so
much personality in the animation yeah
love this
love this really good stuff guy
uh jet I believe
is next
whoa yo hamster ball you yeah
this looks like
yeah two
William to William so is it it's like a
love note are they going to like deliver
a note or do they run away or something
and like left it a girl sending her her
hamster to tell a boy to give a boy
not a note maybe oh my God I think yeah
no that's perfect yeah that's so cute
wow you aced it right there I love how
stable it makes this cuter yeah yeah
he's done this before he messaging he
sends the messages for this person all
over the place twice about running under
those cars
the rendering is great the colors are
great the bloom is great the clarity of
the story is perfect like you'd think
how difficult that'd be like moving so
fast so close up you know it's like no
the they really got the clarity across
yeah beautiful dude seriously this looks
exactly like a couple episodes I've seen
in love death and robots like it's the
exact same aesthetic was it the Rat
episode
the barn the retirement community yeah
yeah this is beautiful
the lighting change under the cars is
scary
also the model of the mouse is really
beautiful and well done
the animation of the eyes like that's
all it has to act with it's just the eye
isn't it works yeah and he's like yeah
it's hard I don't know the challenge of
like animating the creature running in a
ball I guess they're not doing anything
extraordinary but it's a fun it's like
maybe it's harder than it seems you know
to make that seem plausible like there's
the ball bounce but then there's like
the creatures bounce inside the ball
um
yeah it's it's Advanced it's done too
conflict complexly but it's it works
yeah this is this is beautiful it's so
so difficult there's all of these are so
good
um yeah very good stuff chat next up we
have Rob Mulligan
whoa dude I used to have one of those
little car toys oh yeah dude all of us
it does that liquid catalogs dude I love
that goo yeah it was so satisfying Mega
slime Corp this just reminds me of um
Splatoon even though it's not yeah but
okay yeah I can get that Vibe yeah why
are little kids and sunglasses always
funny
because it's them just being old you
know it's like they're ready to grow up
you know
damn the the way the light is shining
through that ooze looks so beautiful
yeah color palette
beautiful it is radioactive
very fun very good stuff I really want
to like build this car
oh man dude you should you should you
should max out one of those little baby
cars
good stuff Rob very good stuff I love
the color of the sky
it contrasts perfectly with the the blue
of the slime
it's nice I feel like that I wouldn't
have that's like an unusual color the
Slime color
you pick for
like a key color or something yeah
really nice
uh next up we have Frederick Fredrick
whoa whoa
oh my God
dude the little slime bits in the mouth
yeah the stringies
dude that thing's that's
that's yeah there's just so much Peril
everyone's in such danger everywhere and
all these these shots dude that hero
with the freaking pickaxe yeah saving
the day
oh man yes like oh
look at my teeth
the driver gets in the eye
like oh really in the eye
oh right in the Resident Evil weak spot
oh my God and it like blinks a little
bit after
disgusting yeah not to mention all the
simulation stuff with that that crash
and like all the debris which yeah
explosion so quickly
freaking beautiful uh
amazing
very good stuff what if they got in
there they've got they've what are they
harvesting it glows whatever it is let's
find out let's let's zoom in fish eggs
monster bug eggs
yeah they must have wronged this guy in
some way they're definitely getting some
like ore
yeah they Disturbed the
the ancient uh the ancient energy within
the cave system yeah that's not good
dude that's
like
in a very vague way give me like uh
Polar Express sort of yes yes I could
see that yeah like the drivers of the
train and that the cartoony or
characters yeah
yeah this one's awesome good stuff
Frederick
alistair's next
little Blade Runner for you okay yo the
camera angle is like more zoomed in here
the flips there's the barrel roll what
is that driver it's like a bot
yeah robot another one-eyed robot
this one is square
head yeah I love I I want to do a coffee
table book of just sci-fi vehicles
undersides and this will definitely go
in that into that dude that would be a
crazy interesting that would be awesome
am I looking what is the motion blur am
I saying stepping in the motion blur
there like the little lines yeah I think
so yeah little streaks I think so
I love the colors on this one though
like the green and yeah yellow orange is
just ah I can't get enough I think
that's an old Corvette but I'm not sure
I mean who's to say it's a flying car so
whatever but and all the steam in the
background makes the city feel so alive
yeah I think it's yeah the city is
intense is it I don't think so I don't
know well I don't know I don't know you
may be right you may be right you think
what
Ferrari ah maybe I don't know
my car skills are not it's a Honda no
it's an it's an accord I don't know
um yeah the
steam the color the render quality the
lighting on this one yeah the reflection
off the side of the vehicle and you can
see all the like the streaks the gross
little streaks yeah the the wheels they
like move in three dimensions yeah like
I guess it's like they're not thrusters
but they're doing something they're
anti-gravity
nodes and like balancing or something
yeah yeah super cool good stuff Alistair
who's next yeah
we got
this one freaking Linus
dude look at that walk oh boy that's
that's an off-road vehicle yeah that's
procedural
that would be amazing the legs yeah
I wouldn't even know where to begin
animating this thing to be honest yeah I
I don't think I would want to do it not
a procedure
yeah God that's gorgeous one and of
course the driver the driver is a crab
right can we can we pause I want to see
oh my God
it's honestly like a crab easier to see
in
but yeah and he's having to
you know what the the it's like a
Flintstones machine equivalent or a crab
because he's having to walk in there
just the same as the machine
like he's specific group the full effort
of walking
look at him there he's like
laughs
I love the this machine I love this
machine you know it feels like a machine
like the the freaking gripper things
they look like an actual sort of like
industrial razor blade yeah
bigger construction vehicle of some sort
yeah it's the design is beautiful and
the background let alone like the the
background and the lighting and the
color my God this is ridiculous yeah the
orange and the crab really come
contrasts nicely with the blue of the
sky like I love that
it's refreshing that there's nothing
really wrong on this world he's just
chilling like he's trying to get to his
next job site yeah and everything's good
man I'm so tired of Carol
all those clouds too
nice good stuff blindness dude there are
white caps in the water
jeez
jeez dude
ridiculous congratulations solid top 100
right here including the birds are the
birds flapping probably
we gotta be no they're like static
of everything else like is perfect but
the birds are just a card they're just
they're just catching the thermals
a bear Big Bear
dude oh wait oh is this from that one
power
I don't know uh like uh uh uh there was
a movie
that came out a long time ago and they
oh uh Beowulf compass yes
oh Beowulf I don't know I'm just saying
things this is beautiful that bear
animation is amazing yeah dude the
background it's like Elden ring
it's gorgeous
yeah for a lot of these I just wonder
what the the philosophy is for a
background because like for something
like this you could just take an
incredible painting or something and
just like stick it in the far distance
and it works but it all matches really
nicely here yeah but they could have
they could have rendered it rendered
just an image of it while after building
it I guess
I feel like the the foreground or the
rather the mid-ground buildings there
giving the sensation
this this Warrior could have just saved
their strength because like the bear
would have knocked the guys out also
notice the Archer up on the hilltop
behind him who's he doing that uh no
just the War I guess there are more than
one
you know
um
yeah this is great the light it's hard
to animate a bear like that come on
that's like
come on
Ah that's freaking great that's great
yeah Lewis killing it Lewis who's next
we got Michael dude this one this one
guys
so creepy this is Clint's spider yeah
this is disgusting like incredible
dude that's freaking smoke in the
background the depravity that must have
occurred like what what messed up thing
I'm not serious about is he is are they
escaping an attack on the the circus or
no they are I think they did it they
caused it they did it I think they had
enough
they're like come on Joe let's go and
they just freaking just take off I feel
like the the pure in undecipherable
expression in their faces like are they
remorseful are they scared are they
excited I don't know no they're freaking
me out Stone Cold you can't tell yeah
that's what makes it so scary he's
smiling dude
the guy in the right casual
and they have their own balloons too ah
the Little Foot Wheels
and I think can drift though yeah dude
truth
this is great the balloons Dynamics are
really nice
no too true in the background balloons
before they I hope they have a backup
plan because having destroyed your
circus like where are you gonna go or
you're a clown you're just gonna have to
find another service no no here's the
thing where he gotta go you're a clown
they're like they're like from a
competing circus they're just like yeah
it's like a raid on the other side of
the valley yeah dueling circuses
oh okay I gotta go to the bathroom I'll
be back for sure I'm down to take a
break you guys want to take five real
quick yeah let's say five sure yeah well
you okay guys we're gonna take five
um
we will be back in five I guess that's
all you need to do to announce a Break
um you're gonna get off to that opening
string render thing that you had yeah
that's a five minute timer how about how
about we do that I'll see you guys in in
five minutes we'll be back here uh keep
your butts in your seats I'll see you
guys in a second
[Music]
oh my God
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
good I've been visited the family oh
sorry I was I was pondering over the
break with the circus one that we just
finished and oh no spoilers of that
story
I I think there's more to this story
because if you look at the tents they're
kind of not just any circles they kind
of look very reminiscent of the specific
design of um earlier Cirque du Soleil
tense yes these are old school clowns
trying to like destroy Cirque du Soleil
the new kind of art nouveau
style circus entertainment that's what
this is so this is the origin circus
versus new circus that's really intense
that's what this is
no that's great I I like it I didn't
know this is how Cirque daisley started
um
but you know you gotta you gotta do what
you got it's a crazy Theory I made up
but you know
it could be real I think I believe I
believe
um and that's a render from Michael
vetteler we are off to the races y'all
um
it's render time baby clown races
do it let's go
um oh from clowns to tanks one Abrams no
no it's not unfortunately not
I would know because I built one out of
cardboard
oh I'm sorry yeah
anyway this is my sister okay nevermind
I see jets this is definitely not World
War one they had biplanes oh no this is
too yeah yeah that looks like uh those
Mustangs
p-51s baby
yeah this is I mean cool render quality
yes
um like filmic cinematic grain yes
um
they got a sweet explosion this is a
shock wave outside of that explosion
oh sick oh yeah I like that
that one German is so confused
he's like okay
the debris oh yeah let's just see the
guy oh yeah he's like wait that was a
tank that's very fast is it a tank the
debris the little Pebbles coming off the
Treads is like I don't even know how you
do that like dim that that sound that
seems complicated it's just like an
emitter back there blasting up at the I
guess maybe I guess so yes
it's nice come to think of it it's very
easy to do yeah
it's a good uh very good detail very
good touch
yeah it was awesome yeah the texturing
is very nice too
good stuff stojon
oh yeah did we lose Peter
can we hear you Peter
oh oh apparently not
Peter Paso whoa
he's muted in Discord there we go sorry
I I was still muted
wait guys there's so much good content I
was saying
we're gonna have to go back we have to
like to redo
okay let's restart
this is like from the top
I love how this one starts out the most
simplistic scene possible even with a
little Gizmo
is it like what what software is being
represented with that
simple shading do you think I guess it's
very non-descript yeah they're keeping
it agnostic this this looks like c4d to
me I guess it looks like that's a c4d
gizmo okay okay okay not familiar
because the green the the Green Arrow
right
um I like so this is like a this is like
a interdimensional 3D
cop yes he's come into rendered view the
pursue
that's actually hilarious like it's a
heist
yeah the money
oh it broke out the safe with the wall
attached to it still oh that's great
that's a great detail they have that MDK
is the name of one of our moderators I
wonder if they put it on there
because of him I don't know but it looks
like they're tiling is like above you
see above the the MDK logo there's like
looks like it's tiling above the window
or just below the window
wait what do you mean you see how like
yeah it's like vertical tiling you see
above that like MDK sticker on the door
oh yeah a little uh safety four I just
thought that was an extra little design
accent yeah an extra detail maybe look
at all the cash they're losing it's not
good that's a that's a high burn rate
what is what is the banner behind the
plane say I don't know I'm trying to
read it
done something
he's like perfect something done perfect
I don't know
better oh perfect
yes it's the same as this thing okay it
is that's great
good stuff Dennis good stuff Dennis very
fun yeah
we got another Ben are those new are
those like cooling towers they are whoa
oh look at that lighting I love the
lighting here
that's gorgeous yeah they're not afraid
to just like let things be dark
oh there seems to be another uh zombie
apocalypse the dude on
there yeah
at the end
it's so nice yeah yeah things are about
to be dark
yeah
agreed
man we almost Imagining the detail there
like you feel like okay yeah it's all
there there might be like almost nothing
built in the bag the back of this that's
a good point it's like you know oh no I
gotta like fill in all this empty space
so it's like well you can turn the
lights down and like maybe just do a
little bit you know
um but man their lighting is great yeah
with the explosion going blowing out
yeah okay
I didn't see the the uh the person being
tortured on the front the very front
okay got it
since this has layers yeah
new things those muzzle flashes
but the big of a gun that is that's such
a big gun that's ridiculous
it's like
that's that's that's absurd dude run it
sounds like you're giving a speech to 10
000 people right now
wait what your mic feedback is is
happening oh
this gun is so big
sorry I apologize I was uncalled for oh
it was perfect it was perfect it is
beautiful that is by Ben shout outs to
our boy Ben very cool let's see
who's next we got
this is by Cornell
everyone's a crash test dummy
no audience
that's great
so cool
yeah oh man
95 there goes away what is what's it's
like inside the car or something yeah oh
it's like a little light like the way
Uber or something like that has a little
glowing medallion
okay yeah I just thought it was a stamp
on top of the glass at first let's do
all the confetti yeah it's so such a
nice detail
I love the like they're in they're in
some sort of city like look at that like
ancient architecture back there like
they're in the middle of Italy or
something and it's like a pop-up race
track
cool pop-up race track
oh the the crash test dummy Society is
very Advanced they have a history wait
look at the person
okay can you guys see my mouse
yeah yeah look at this person right here
this person right here ready
I'm just getting down not their own
thing like not even looking at the race
that's great that's hilarious yeah
really nice lighting really nice
animation render quality
um love the like filmic cinematic vibe
to this they did a really good job with
the color correction dude also just the
smoke yes getting caught in the light
yes how do we keep seeing the same thing
every time Ren it like syncs up
perfectly every single time but yeah
right look how good it looks
ah atmosphere of it all yeah amazing
really good stuff uh Cornell
congratulations
um I think I messed up
[Music]
what did I do hold on there's a dark
scene here we'll keep going with it this
one's similar this one's similar
oh nice
it's like that scene from invincible
foreign
I love that like intro with the jump
there is so cool yeah really nice
physics and like the helicopter
Spotlight it's like
there's like a handoff of action where
like the the vehicle is like doing all
these Bob but then when it's stable you
got other things going on yeah like a
little
yeah all of these like you know
the the real the real nice renders they
have that mid action Moment Like This
little shift there's a part two to the
render yeah and like the camera the
camera stops to just like stay on the
car that gets mad like it's a nice exit
sorry I guess the camera it just he just
speeds out of it okay never mind but it
looks like yeah
if it's intentional or if it uh was just
because of the way it was uh like
calculated the motion blur but the way
that the bodies have like one frame of
no motion blur right in front of the car
looks so cool oh yeah
well let's let's check it out because
the exposure would make it uh or the
light would make it expose better oh
you're right yeah yeah yeah and then I
guess they stop just for a second as
they get hit yeah because they're they
didn't hit to the same thing I guess you
get better yeah
so brutal so intense so cool yeah yeah I
love this I love this visceral yeah
that's good stuff it's by Lynn Lynn you
on Manuel yeah I was gonna make that
man he's so multi-talented
could you imagine I'm driving on the 101
the other week really was he singing
no he but he was in a black convertible
like with the thing down here is Black
sunglasses and he was just vibing
chilling dang nice this is by wansie
wanzai oh that's beautiful yeah I love
this so cool render quality is really
nice I love the color I could feel like
I could touch those little paper lantern
fish
are all the is are all the characters
the same I think so yeah they look like
little I think so wait you're in the or
the girl's imagination I wish I was
there
oh yeah
yeah I love that you can clearly see the
structure inside of the fish you know
yeah
yeah it's really nice model
um they really nailed the like
illuminescent glow
paper lantern look
beautiful really nice yeah this one's
cool expecting the Huns to attack I know
right just crouched on the roof on the
peak it's like it's like The Operators
of the lanterns are like being nice to
the kids she's like go and they speed up
you know that's cute
yeah super cool love it beautiful good
stuff onesie
uh Boris
is next Taurus effects wow
dude this is straight out of the Batman
yeah yeah
[Music]
damn that looks really good and also
exactly like the movie yeah that's the
overexposure of the explosion for such a
long time you said you do or don't
choice
I do yeah it's like it's kind of just
like who are you that's what it would
look like it's not gonna make it all
beautiful in every frame yeah like
agreed totally it'll be way overblown
that's like one of the biggest things I
love about this
um is it feels very realistic it feels
like a movie
um though they're doing a great job with
the rain
um the particles out the back of the car
wait I even think the where it hits the
car and the tail of it gets spun back I
think that's literally in the movie
really
yeah I remember that detail geez maybe
we should compare
per shot
[Music]
cool yeah this one's cool this one's
well done super sick it's a great
explosion too I know ah
by Boris
really good stuff for us yeah awesome
awesome
um Jonathan stopler is next
dude
is this Indiana Jones yeah flux
capacitor on the car or something oh my
God
no the the radiator dies and starts
kicking out smoke oh yeah
but what's the triangle there's there is
a flux capacitor in there I think it's
just a homage you were saying it's a
bunch of Spielberg but that's nice
yeah huh it's it's just a classic movie
you guys see the Triceratops
yeah that's cool back there
oh
yeah okay
yeah
yeah they got a lot of stuff that
Clashing of style before with like
dinosaurs you know like a freaking model
T kind of sweet yeah it was fun yeah I'm
down I'm down for it this one's cool
they really spent a lot of time on
getting the the forest looking right and
building out this giant forest and
getting the lighting correct
um is that a temple there's a whole
freaking Aztec Temple yeah yeah
super nice this is like
a Jurassic Park prequel that would be
smart to do like they figured it out
once before in the past and what was
that like
love it yeah good stuff good stuff
Jonathan congrats man
uh Noah
well whoa whoa Michelin whoa
yo
I was that guy once in a YouTube
original
that's so sick the dude the lighting on
the little Michelin man or the Doughboy
I don't know what but
is so creepy to me
like like
under lighting is creepy right but when
it's under lit it's marshmallow man
that's just a thing oh it's a
marshmallow man
stay positive yeah boy
no it's from the Ghostbusters
I think he's an original
original legally distinct entity that is
doughboy-esque called yesterday puffed
marshmallow man yeah oh I'm sure you're
right that sounds this is the uh this is
the Ghostbusters Universe here
yeah right yeah good mashup that's crazy
bust us
the light is great I got the first frame
with just that Moonlight pretty sick
yeah also is the ground glowing like
getting or those lights on the ground
well I think they're in the Airfield
yeah it's like
oh wait those are the little things that
you suck the ghosts into aren't they oh
uh what is they might
they might be
a ton of them a whole two of them that's
so awesome just great animation great
lighting
ridiculous yeah I want to see this
transformation real quick
yeah
so the head is in the hood
and it goes things in the hood that's
just like just like motion very
satisfying
City
so from here I saw a thing disappear
there okay okay yeah that goes in and
out the hands oh so the hands tuck Up
and Under and cover the face
yeah the head Ducks under covers his
face and then boom and just a simple
choice of like the life's just done come
on it's so yeah I don't know that makes
me happy for some reason because a
silhouette
that's the way that it would be done in
an 80s movie like things would just turn
on and that would be a visual that is
one dirty marshmallow by the way that is
he's definitely passed the five second
rule burning he's burning right is he
not oh yeah or no wait
no he's just dirt wait no it's coming on
wait does he explode does he explode oh
no okay we catch it we want to we want
to see more
yeah looks exactly like the like a like
a new version of the old movie also like
what an epic silhouette on those dudes
there just like they're Powers
there doesn't need to be any texturing
on them at all because it's the
silhouette is all you need dude and look
how scary that is like he's like I'm
getting destroyed but I'm laughing at
you
that is so scary dude uh Noah
congratulations that is an awesome
render yeah
Pedro Pascal is next
what I'm sorry what no it's Pedro it's
just Pedro
Pedro sures wait
okay this has got like a wow well AI
filter on top
oh
so I'm cool
yeah this one's sick I like how it I
like that really works for the character
getting in like it's just
there's this dynamicness to them yeah
nice and fluid it's like cyberpunk John
Wick yeah that's the best way to put it
yeah 100
oh wow this is beautiful yeah I love it
whoa wait I'm gonna a car passes through
the bike so fast it explodes afterwards
the speed wobbles on the bike
like it actually has realistic speed
wobble oh yeah that's nice yeah
dang that's super cool I like this yeah
you know the style here is really cool
too yeah
this is like how I imagine there is a
little bit of like a stable diffusion
filter over this though I think so oh
definitely yeah if not I would like to
know the technique of how they would
have done it
you know without involving AI that would
be fascinating yeah you know really cool
love those speed wobbles good stuff
Pedro
congrats
we got the most realistic motorcycle
animation I've ever seen yeah it's
really good it's really good oh my God
yeah Daniel Smith that's incredible dude
that is the cutest Play-Doh car ever
look at the expression
just the minimalism of the animation is
so good yeah it goes through it goes
through like three three different
Expressions yeah and how it's not this
and it's so engaging it's like new
shapes up here
for the eyes
oh good point and and like the the grade
on it is like this like it looks like a
thing from the 60s or something
like yeah
the depth of field is like that's so
shallow yeah the fuzz
yeah because that's those are Hot Wheels
that's a Hot Wheel Hot Wheels on the
right
that's a Hot Wheels
yeah and the car the scale of the carpet
yeah just right mm-hmm
dude we were just talking about that on
react yesterday too like the scale of
fuzz on a on a blanket or a carpet like
that when you scale it up you can't do
it large scale and have it look like
it's small
oh man like it's a model or something
model the follicles or or at least like
have particle hair in their little hairs
yeah little little that's the right just
the right scale of it sweeped splines
scattered across the carpet or something
yeah that's nice I I just I just love
the expression it goes from like seeing
the world for the first time as a
newborn child yeah and then like it's
very adorable you realize oh we got some
competition these guys I think they mean
business and then you have a good time
you know what I love that little side
eye he does it's like that that emoji
with like the half like the diagonal
mouth is like
yeah you know what I really love this
one it's awesome I like this one too
yeah the story of it it's cute brings
out the good the childhood for sure the
way the different pieces are separated
as it's hitting the ground
oh yeah freaking awesome
speeds up his rear tires get bigger
oh that's cool
wow I'm going to succeed in this life
good stuff
dude so many of these need to be movies
I know I know yeah like keep it up guys
and I just gotta say real quick to
everyone who
you know we hadn't gotten through the
top 100 yet but you know if
if you guys don't make top 100 that's
okay you know the whole point is that
you guys had a good time along the way
and you learned some stuff and you had
fun and you met some people doing it and
um you know I'm gonna put them all in
its in their own all renders Montage too
um of course we'll have the top 100
Montage but I just hope you guys are
having fun and enjoying these renders
along with us and
um yeah it's not the end of the world
you know it's just all all good times
people still down in the chat
yeah they in there there's another
Universe out there and we did get into
the 100. yeah let's talk about that
and there's people that that join that
don't make it the first three four times
but you know they make it in this one so
it's it's cool yeah so good stuff Daniel
good stuff
wait I saw comments in the Plato window
highlight
let's see
let's see one more viewing real quick oh
yeah
dude
oh it's good that's good
that's good man that's good
good stuff Daniel
it's amazing we got
Peter Eric Hoffman
this one's crazy it's one of those like
little mechanical uh stage things I
don't know what you call them
so the background is like spinning and
the tree Rock things spinning
wow yeah yeah
I like I love this yeah it's like a
diorama little sticks maybe you can see
the sticks yeah like a diorama
crazy like what an idea like how do you
get this idea yeah he's like carved out
of wood or something like everything is
a little old-timey yeah miniature oh my
God ren do you remember when we were in
Minnesota and we saw that like oh no you
were you were in the bathroom the whole
show I forgot about your oh shoot
okay that's sick
moving on
um anyway Peter
um this is this is great this is awesome
I love the dark Vibes on this
congratulations man good stuff good
stuff
uh who's next we saw this one
um I did a little flip-flop this is
Lucas
this is just clean clean and juicy yeah
damn that's super clean yeah
that car's so cool yep like sometimes it
really helps renters to add like surface
imperfections and and like ugliness to
it like intentionally but sometimes
having a really clean look to something
really elevates it
yeah it's like commercial status oh yeah
the background has a lot of grime uh to
it but then the foreground you know it
it makes the Clean Car feel so much
cleaner
and it's not hiding behind like extra
camera Shake too much motion blur it's
just like what you see is what you get
and it looks good yeah you just can't
explain why it's just good
also I'm always super impressed when
people in CG manage to get like the sun
glint perfect like on the bleachers in
the back at the end oh good point the
Sun hitting that and flaring out the
lens
looks really good yeah yeah this is I
want to hear the sound design on this
you know that's just yeah
for example aspect ratio requirement
yes okay
I just realized we're not looking at
16x9 renders correct yeah they're
they're two three five yeah okay
um good stuff Lucas killing it love it
love it love it love it next up we got
naricio americium
whoa Speed Racer oh cool yeah
wow yeah this one is nutty dude
great animation I know
I know the little legs that come out of
the car it's just so fast I know it's
ridiculous we're ripping like it feels
like a little Overexposed but
I don't know it's also great
I mean like it's like
kind of add a little bit of greediness
to the otherwise very
Bubblegum the wobble it gets when it's
on the two two tires there like yeah
and that's sweet
it is car have four things I'm trying to
remember the old cartoon I always have
like a memory of just two things coming
out
I don't know I I I didn't watch much
Speed Racer when I was a kid
mm-hmm
super cool yeah they also
oh go ahead Peter it's like I was just
gonna say the logo is uh looping at the
end but that's like no that's literally
what I was gonna say
there yeah
yeah like it's like it's like they had
the focus a little off on the camera in
real life and it's like oh well we just
got to use the shot anyway we didn't
nail the focus setting it's there's
something about that makes it
subliminally realistic I guess I love it
the take is not perfect
yeah so good
um amazing work Mauricio love it great
animation just great overall
um oh man this one's freaking cool these
are also cool this is Aditya
whoa whoa
oh my gosh that is a very cool sudden
transformation yeah dude that jet design
is so Sleek look dude the whole design
of the character
this is the this this is the first time
I see a Transformer type robot transform
in a way that's like yeah he would do
that like it's not some crazy complete
reconfiguration yeah
I don't know they all should do it I
don't know how you'd even begin
doing honestly what
it's ridiculous yeah those air trails
oh yeah and also he he totally Nails the
the monster
right yeah right the weak point yeah one
shot
only thing I wish is just a bigger
explosion that's it
um I just want like a just an earth
shattering these are like the
preliminary ones and then one big flash
point
yeah for the whole thing oh man it's
like charging up that's so sweet yeah
yeah the light they're lighting
go ahead Peter I'm impressed by the
scale of the city yeah oh yeah they're
doing a really good job with their like
little atmospheric cards um or
volumetrics to like add depth to the
city otherwise it'd be kind of a lame
without it you know yeah yeah
wow beautiful well beautiful Aditya
we got
MDK Mr UC
megacorp wiggin
whoa
[Laughter]
yeah the hydrant water is its own little
claymation style oh my God this is so
good yeah
[Music]
that's so fun yeah it's not just like
claymation but like children's modeling
clay that's that the real Old Clay
that's very shiny
straight from a 60s child's imagination
yeah freaking awesome really good work
he was really trying to like
get the elevation
thing working
um because it's like obviously going
downhill but
I think that's a pretty interesting like
interpretation on the rules
really nice all right you're align
yourself with the with the surface of
the road yeah
I made a steamrolling man crushing it
it's so good
[Laughter]
yeah expression on the face
he's like oh
yeah it's awesome does he go from like
from a character to just flat like is
there any transition
dude look I'm just minding his own lips
business I know
oh okay there's something cool oh
[Laughter]
yes that's great yeah good stuff MDK
good stuff man congrats
um we got madis Daniel oh man you guys
are gonna like this one
it's another uh is this like a Gundam oh
my God whoa oh
wow
[Music]
Jesus the aesthetic is just absolutely
on point yeah
yeah it's all about the aesthetic on
this one
cool transition too
oh my gosh there's like a
right before the the cards come up yes
there's like a almost like a paint error
in the cell like keep going
yeah like the the outlines go like
sometimes I think that's a thing oh
wow
so cool
what a detail
[Music]
huh this is nuts see you now loops
around and transitions into the jet
oh that's freaking cool that's
incredible yeah
beautiful this is by Midas yeah congrats
really awesome
who's next we got MO
wow no oh is this for another one Blade
Runner
no this is this is
yeah that looks great yeah those colors
man it's like again there's those greens
I just love those greens so much
the world design and cinematography yeah
the rain look at the rain like in the
light
sparkly I know it's great they got the
train back there they really built this
out
wow nice
yeah
yeah this building in the forest there's
like yeah
design is it Ryan Gosling in there in
the in the driver's seat
is it I don't know or just or Harrison
Ford straight up kind of looks like one
or both of them
I don't know it looks like make some
Mojo young Harrison
dude it's it's Jake Watson it does look
like Jake wants to get the handlebars
and the passenger is there any even a
passenger there is a passenger
we're seeing things I think it's like a
side of a seat
yeah
make some Mojo and miximo Jane having a
have a good old stroll through the Cyber
City
yeah that's good stuff Mo congrats uh
beautiful lighting beautiful render
quality beautiful animation
um yeah just good stuff all around man
congrats
we got Terry
coming up next
ah this one's freaking sweet
oh it's like a Warhammer thing it feels
like it I don't know if it is but it
definitely feels right
oh uh
kind of oh yeah that Star Wars property
I can't think it was like the
Stormtroopers not a bad batch but uh
um the cartoon series from yeah
yeah I forget the name of that the Clone
Wars yes
yeah yeah very similar style that sounds
right
I just love like everything that's going
on here and they're clearly he's like
rolling in with his crew and
you know just chopping up some dinosaurs
or something I don't know but yeah I I
was this was too fast for us for our
Earth kind to perceive this level of
action oh my God they got the freaking
the planes do the vortices on the smoke
that's a great teacher wow
that's fun
oh man that's so good
so good wow yeah I'm a fan I love the
color on this one
um and just like the cartoony Style on
it
oh the castles back there it's so cool
so cool good stuff there's by Terry
amazing work Terry uh next up we have
another
Fabricio oh my God guys this one oh yeah
oh yeah jeez
oh dude no nuts
I love that that evil bug in the
background tripping and flipping and the
fact that it spins like a car crash yeah
and it's got like a little blade that
comes out and then sticks in the ground
like a sword fish
this one this is crazy because this guy
he was sharing his work pretty early on
the the server and um
like he inspired a ton of renders so
many other vendors had this kind of like
Chase in a little like like dipping
under logs and stuff yeah a lot of
people saw this and was like this is
awesome
um I just love that the little antennas
of the bug it looks like the legs of the
rider and it just makes me laugh every
time
the animation is ridiculous
like he's driving the bug but the bug is
assessing the situation in this cute way
he's like yeah
oh it's like two drivers yeah
the the
this is like the bottom body in the
upper body
yeah oh yeah whoa that's cool it's like
it's like its own shocks that's what it
uses for shots yeah yeah
he's man yeah ridiculous I just noticed
the gnome
I know yeah
The Gnome watches all over all
like I don't know if for all I know the
the animation on the actual legs is just
gibberish and it's not like really
realistic but it just works because it
sells this kind of stylized scene so
fast I know adorable like the weight
transfer too good too good Fabricio too
good calm it down over there I love how
aggressively evil that background bug
thing looks like it looks mean I know
yeah just killing it killing it good
stuff we got Adam
Zander next oh what the I love this one
dude oh yeah whoa oh yeah
okay I've I've not seen this kind of
style before this is cool very original
looking
overcooked or something yeah
yeah it does the animation of the guy's
face is so good
he's just minding his own business like
he didn't expect this you know
that exhausting pipe just like flexing
yeah wow
wow I want to live in this world I know
I wanna I wanna set this up in my
bathtub
this is what was happening in the
bathtub in my mind when I was little too
oh 100 yeah getting sucked like sucked
in like almost drowned you know brutal
um the clouds I love the like chopped
bottom of those clouds is cool
yeah yeah
and it's so simple like the the foliage
is just like squished spheres but it
works so well yeah they look like M M's
now it's it Teeters on this Cliff of
like it it has the feeling of toys and
claymation but it's also kind of being
like early CG where it's like I'm not
trying too hard to make this very
tactile yeah and it's giving me like
both things at once on two different
channels it's fun I feel that yeah yeah
it kind of gives me the feeling like it
was designed uh with a program that like
you could only use Primitives and stuff
you know like like you have access to a
bunch of spheres that you can squash and
stretch and whatnot and
not that it was made that way just it
that's the time that's the idea
intentionally yeah the design language
is very consistent in this one I love it
so much fun
um good stuff Adam congratulations on
top 100 and we got Alex next this one is
insane guys oh dang we're in an office
whoa whoa It's so fast oh my God what is
this
happen right off that is incredible oh
dude
dude I think I love just inexplicable
dots look at look at the name of this
company what is the place called yeah
yeah yeah
this poor lady he drops out of the the
building
now she's
dead
that's funny yeah
I love you yeah it's good it's like the
shortest Pixar short ever made
yeah this one this one's very fun love
the intensity
kick into wave is perfectly animated
he's having a good time like he's he's
doing this on purpose you know
wait does his clothes get knocked off
yes okay okay that's too funny yeah he's
blown off
when he hits it his chair gets slammed
into the ceiling what he lands on
someone else let's go frame by frame one
more time
yeah I love the frame by frame
oh my God
it's in the ceiling and then uses his
pants
uh everything there goes
dude her back will be broken
what happens at the end like they die
they go out the window dude
wait okay his shirt is already like
unbuttoned at the beginning
I guess it's ready to be simmed
off of his body sure sure yeah so good
Alex we love it man congratulations he's
a great one
yeah yeah
super soft it's a Far Side cartoon as a
CG short like why is this happening
totally yeah it has that style of
character
uh Brandon
Brandon
huh
dude a freaking Sky Surfer
that's cool yeah this reminds me of snow
crash
Throne is not messing around not playing
games that's for sure
yeah I love the anime Vibes on this the
aesthetic so good it's really nice
probably took as much work to do those
the the Marquee the and Dancer animation
up there on the screen as the rest of it
too there's somebody into like
there's somebody surfing on the back of
the car there at the last second
oh yeah it comes from the comes from the
monorail
top comes down okay okay okay it's true
the impact of those bullets is so nice
yeah that's beautiful
nice I wonder for anything that's on a
board that you ride sideways especially
if it flies
oh man there's a one wheel render
actually
is it in the top 100 unfortunately not
it almost made it it almost made it it
almost made it
dang it you got it you got to see that
one yeah absolutely
um good stuff Brandon love the style man
really really fun
I have
yeah
they can just totally feel how to make
the this is fun this is Candyland yeah
over sugar overload it's like that Mario
Kart level
yeah this is straight out of that movie
uh Wreck-It Ralph oh is it oh cool like
there's like that Candy level that the
one little girl is in where like
everything's made out of candy I think
and they're racing okay yeah candy tires
look really nice I know right in the
drawers
I think so
yeah it could be
huh that's beautiful it's like a
jawbreaker helmet
oh that's awesome oh man
as smart
that's so great yeah I love the like
intensity of this one they really nailed
the lighting and they got the animation
super solid there's a freaking airplane
in the background just doing a random
barrel roll for fun yeah just arbitrary
tricks
arbitrary tricks
that's great yeah all the big snow Puffs
too super cool yeah that's a good one
yeah this one's great congrats Stars
subtle rainbow in the background
yeah I feel like I ate Candy from
watching it on a loop I know right I
feel like I need to stop Sugar Rush yo
that if they sh okay you should name the
sugar rush I'm just saying All Right
Moving On
this is by Jonas Noel
oh yeah
ridiculous man that smoke yeah
the smoke the dust out the back is so
cool and like the the weird like
um what's the best word for this the
bullet hits you see the bullet hits how
they're just like these weird shapes and
super distorted
oh come on now it hits on the car
oh no whoa they're like these different
shapes and stuff like I don't even know
what that is but it looks awesome yeah I
gotta point out the the lack of counter
steering on that drift though just
saying
yeah I see ya this looks great though
this looks straight out of say Fast and
the Furious yeah or literally that one
scene and what was it uh Need for Speed
that one scene
in the desert
I think I didn't realize the helicopter
is one of those ones with the double
counter spinning blades
oh that's cool toys a lot but rarely in
actually does that does that exist yeah
I don't even know well because they have
the rear rotor to fix that right yeah
it's it's mechanically a lot more
complex to do it that way uh for an
actual vehicle uh but for a toy a small
scale thing it's easier to do it that
way interesting and it's cool though
very cool yeah the render quality and
the lighting and the colors and the
animation is just ridiculous on this one
the textures engaging little
moment agreed yeah agreed really good
stuff Jonas congrats to you man can't
wait to set this to music oh my God
that's gonna be so good that's next
no not next week I think next no it is
next week it is next week
wait
dude that sword that comes out
like is it fold out oh no she just hit
something oh I love it just so in your
face
composited
yeah yeah
I could see that
or it's just on different uh separates
oh that's what it is the background's on
once and that is like on fours or
something yeah the the foregrine actions
so
um copy like it's on purpose
but like maybe it was all one render and
yeah like they just stepped them in
different ways the different layers
either way it's super sweet yeah I'm a
big fan it's like that
I don't know early 2000s
is it like a reference to something I
don't know
I feel like it's going for something
I am nailing it whatever it is like
daytime cartoon Vibes yeah yeah we're
like the sun is reflecting off of the
the glass in the buildings and stuff
yeah this is um I am very impressed they
managed to get an Akira slide in this
laughs
yeah and it works fits man oh totally
crazy
yeah this is amazing this is by Drac
Drac lad
I mean Ren wouldn't wouldn't they need
to be leaned the other way to be moving
in that direction as they're skidding
don't you have a problem with that
yeah
I guess it works either
oh man that's awesome I'm confused what
she's chopping though
uh
yeah me too
Pastor the sword extends to all the way
to the pursuing oh what is the missile
oh
passed and then came back the missile is
redirected at the robot wait so hold on
but the missile the missile knocks out
the robot without exploding
she is faster than the missile
went forward and then came back around
right
unclear
but it's definitely headed back the
other way it bounces it it bounces off
him it explodes across along the ground
against the ground
say
sick
um yes egg Drac lad uh Harold
whoa
dude is that a Furby
Furby it's totally affirming obliterated
what an explosion
it's like so cute and it's like all
right captain
that's great that's great driver is like
pedaling so fast he is
he's very skilled at this another one of
those inverted frames on the explosion
too indeed yeah let's take a look
straight up freaking 255 all around whoa
whoa like some hand-painted dude
that's so cool what damn charcoal it's
amazing they busted out the charcoal and
the graphite what does what does Bender
say like that guy's not coming home to
his kids they
there's not even a skeleton
that's just ash that's
that's the best whoa this this just
leveled up in my mind
yeah that definitely looked hand drawn
yeah that was so cool man that must have
been fun
that really does help sell the impact of
an explosion like that yeah
dang that was sweet that's inspiring
what did they do
they just had a tail a tail light out oh
yeah yeah
you didn't have a rear license plate you
need to install that you know
didn't put your new tags on
the police cars have freaking tusks
they mean business dude they mean
business that's awesome Harold also
they're gonna tackle uh do the the pin
maneuver or whatever oh yeah
sick love it
love it love it
Moritz maurits is next I love this the
colors on this I wanna whoa yeah I want
to play this game oh my God that guy's
ripped yeah
a robot
bodybuilder dog
hey
it's a bird doing a bear
[Applause]
we saw a bird do that I'm not even
kidding oh man yes it's hilarious
perfect these colors are gorgeous I know
nicely dude I just want to like have
this as like a little bathtub toy would
be so cool
look at the propeller um yeah
there's there is no propeller just speed
lines yeah no model no uh geometry oh I
think it's hand-drawn but then put on
like a card yeah like as an emissive
yeah that's really smart like these are
some these are some cool techniques you
guys look at the foam too oh the foam
that sub subsurface like milk
what do you say
nothing
don't worry about it wait are you saying
something about the way I say milk no uh
no don't worry about it has nothing to
do with you look at the little bubble
going down the tube
the little uh inflatable thing there's
like a Thruster in the back
he's got like a little oh cool oh okay
yeah
that's like the engine whoa so simple
but so effective
yeah this one's fun this is Maurice good
stuff
Nicholas
look at that what
look at that
dude what the heck kind of a so cool
yeah
definitely Ghibli Vibes here
like the characters like Dexter's
Laboratory or something yeah like
drawing style oh my God I just realized
so he's pressing forward for each leg
thing and when the legs fall off and
then he's having to do this really fast
oh that's genius
Ah that's awesome I love incredible I
know the like the texture painted on the
side of this thing is super cool
hmm
dang
yeah big fan on stuff Nicholas Daw
crushing it man crushing it
who do we got
who we got Nils our boy Nils
whoa what
this one's this one is absurd guys
dude the freaking turkey turkey skeleton
mountains
that's disgusting dude is he stealing
eggs
I'm gonna make you a turkey Slurpee
[Laughter]
yeah they're stealing eggs
this all these characters
feeling natural resources from the
creatures they belong to how
too
really wondering
mad eggs is the is their license plate
mad maze oh mad Megs
I read that wrong
this is crazy the monster turkey is
very cool yeah yeah
dude that's so good wait where'd that
bone come from
wait wait what
it just
I don't know
oh
they're hitting a bunch of Bones on the
under the wheels there in the back so
maybe oh there's a giant skeleton
oh yeah yeah okay
there's like so much info packed in
visitors
oh and the turkey just got nailed by a
rib
oh my God
these are like the vehicle has these
tractor wheels that are like from the
80s onto his eyelid
wait can we can we follow the animation
of that one guy or yeah yeah
he popped up okay there he is
wait which one is he is he the blue one
on the hanging from the wheel well
and he comes back down and catches the
eye like
dude
it takes out the turkey
really
he left his they left their Bud behind
though
yeah well what can you do Nils that's
incredible congrats man can't make an
omelette without breaking a few drinks
sorry yes
hypnotoads Grandpa
this is like yeah yes
no that's it oh okay yeah well that's it
yeah this is ridiculous like what on
Earth Pleasant I know I don't want to
just grab the creature and squeeze him
yeah look at the little except not the
on the from the back not the end Trail
Parts oh yes that's gross touch them
look at the little like
Flaps in the back
this little back flaps are just
so this is the world underwater I guess
it is I would think so yeah oh that
makes sense yeah this is what I was
hoping quantumania was gonna be
notice I just noticed like his pupils
that dilate actually have like a little
bit of that bounce they dilate and they
go oh yeah like a like a yeah but what
what else
look at its little giblet sacks dude is
the original like the original
the render is like really high res I
just want to zoom in on the eyeball I
know I want to see the detail of it I
know as it transforms it looks wait are
those little sacks on his back like
transparent they go from like brown to
green and yeah they are I think they
have some eggs
oh dude I don't even want to know
this is so this is like this is so maxed
out
and all of the stuff in the background
like just the the alien detail going on
in every every pixel
it's incredible
yeah really nice wow really nice
um could stuffly
we got our boy Benjamin up next
oh okay yeah
they got that that's nice to see some
behind the scenes yeah
yeah is that a Lego guy in there yeah
there's some like Lego pieces
This Is How They really did Fury Road
that's that No Effects my butt
is that lost BTS Like stop motion the
the cable at the back car throws whoa
cool
that's awesome it's amazing yeah
I want to key this out and like put
something right do they even they even
have like a little black Clippers
holding up the the the green cardboard
in the back love it is this surrender
yeah definitely really good definitely
yeah I'm a fan this one's awesome look
dude look at a little like all these
little pieces and stuff like this will
have a heck of a Time greet uh keying
the cactuses there oh no oh no
I'm a little confused
yeah that's uh yeah it's like a mix of
styles I guess the environment is Lego
but the cars are toys like it's somebody
just did it with the what they had yes
the little Lego exhaust coming out of
the car though when it boosts
yeah and then like the dirt you see all
the Dust
in the wheel it's so cool
good stuff Benjamin love it love it
Tino Tino Klein we got more Legos
oh Lego star oh my dude what if
[Music]
what were you gonna say what what if
that's how that actually happened in the
movie he jumps I just noticed tiny
little Invaders going yeah he's like
[Laughter]
[Music]
I keep expecting to see the ship fly by
behind Alan like just by the window
it's like when you watch a car chase on
TV and then they're like on your street
oh yeah there it goes there it goes
this is well done yeah nice little uh
Lego Star Wars Trench Run yeah with the
Twist on what we already know
yeah look at the explosion How It's Made
whoa like all the little Lego debris
like that oh yeah okay
beautiful yeah what's what's happening
with the explosion is interesting it's
like some kind of
just dissolves between these static sort
of
painted Mayhem like frames
yeah let's see
it's like happening it's not overlaid
it's inside it's a real thing yeah
that's super cool
and like it's like something it gets
like painted up at the end all right Z
death pass huh Maybe
I think it's made of Legos
even the like the light oh it is made of
Legos yeah
crazy it just has like a color fade fall
off thing there's like a couple of
frames they're just kind of
I'm warping I guess right there yeah
wow that's crazy
good stuff Tino love it love it
who's next we got our boy Leon I love
this oh man I love this oh yeah yeah oh
my God it's perfect 16 bit yeah yeah
there's this game signalus that I've
been playing and it's totally like this
this um art style it's so cool
there's also this game heart shot that's
going to come out that's going to be
super sweet and it's gonna be this hard
style as well I saw a mobile game for
that that's right so I'm like a mobile
ad for that game no don't don't look at
that one don't look at that one
this is incredible yeah yeah this is by
yeah Leon
um just dig the style man the style and
the animation is good too you know how
do you achieve this kind of style
getting that like that pixel art type
look because this is like a post filter
on top of it all like it has to be right
but like how I don't think so so you
render without texture filtering at all
and there's an After Effects plugin
called retro dither that will did their
things but I don't think this is
dithered
it just looks like a little bit depth
huh but like look at the lines in the
road they're consistent like they look
like they're actually painted
an individual little lines like that you
know it's pretty crazy if you if you
make a version that's low resin up and
has no filtering of any kind and then
blow it back up I assume it would give
you that
like aliasing just like what it really
looks like without
any kind of conversion yeah yeah like it
doesn't blend it's not trying to blend
pixels or colors yeah
I wonder it's doing some kind of but
like the scale of the aliasing changes
across the shot like if you look at the
detail of the highlights on the front of
his uh versus the scale of the aliasing
on the the yellow stripes on the road
yeah they must have applied it to like
different passes of it or something yeah
background or maybe separate from the
bike probably yeah that's probably how
I'd do it
also The Recoil and the animation from
the bump that it goes over is really
nice
yeah very subtle but very effective the
attacking creatures are like they have
little Halos yeah I feel like they're
the good guys wait from Heaven does he
die
oh or she oh hey that's dark it's it's a
she just gets nailed yo down B it's a
straight up down B
that's unexpected oh okay oh
my god well it goes off the rail oh and
it goes up
dude
oh my God that's crazy I love it there's
new stuff to me
how many police officers will be get
blown away in these
oh man cool stuff Leon uh next up we
have a name I
I mean it's l x u g a i n g l
sweet
Bowser
oh dude oh man that's great
Oh Baby Mario is that baby yeah
I'm glad that that Bowser survived the
explosion now this is classic Mario Kart
this is only saying that because you
played Bowser in Smash no
I love that like these are actual like
Mario uh carts though like that's the
that's the ship cart yeah that's one of
the best carts like no joke
and the tiny little tires for quick
acceleration mm-hmm yeah and like
dropping a bomb like that classic with
the drip go into the drift out yeah
that's this is if you guys don't know
Mario Kart
Mario Kart is is my life it's my life
yeah it's it's for it being your life
it's unfortunate you're so bad at it
though
dude it's it's bad it's like smash I
don't know if I ever told my Mario Kart
story on stream but it's it's a brutal
story it's so sad oh God that's the
story for another time another time
another time
they're going for a stop-motion thing
here too something about the way they
move I feel like they just did it frame
by frame
the the actions
I didn't I didn't really feel that
no you you don't
is it like the jerky animation Kinda
Yeah like they're I mean it's not that
jerky but it's like
I wouldn't be surprised if they were
going yeah like
and minimal and stuff
I love it I choose to believe
that's what they were going for
good stuff uh lxu jingle
uh next one is by Hoon
or something snail is that
whoa whoa whoa what the heck
it's a little teacup then it gets a
chrome faceplate oh my God cool he's
getting chased by like little salt and
pepper shaker things
most exciting like transformation
moments in all of these is when
something just pops on for no reason
like that when the way the windshield is
just there
I mean it's like a frame yeah it's just
exciting also those are teacups in the
background I just realized oh my God
teacups Mountain teacups
okay yeah yeah oh snap this is wild
it's a cup world
it seems like he's like some kind of
some kind of cuphead
is a little
no but it's a t it's like tea time
it's a cup and then there's a teapot and
then
I want to know more
a surprising number of robots with arm
legs
in in this top 100 I mean like just in
the renders it's like this is that at
least the third one fourth one yeah Alan
what's your what's your take on the
story here what's your best guess
I I mean
so at worst the offense is trespassing
because I don't see the character
carrying anything we've seen many of
these guys stealing resources uh but uh
you know so far I think I think he's
just trespassing and
I love these are like are they are they
salt and pepper shakers or something
these that's what they look like guys
they've got they have those little holes
yeah industrial pepper string
dude industrial salt and pepper shakers
they're like 20 pounds each
I love it forks for arms good stuff
who's next who's next
Alex is next
yo that car got some air whoa oh
that collateral damage
dude
submarine at the end it's about time
seagull Wing doors lived up to their
name
truth
nice that helicopter just destroying
that Prius
is this man in a tuxedo in that
helicopter
really oh it looks like it kind of looks
like that into James Bond situation
mm-hmm
this is sweet
it reminds me of the Harry Potter car
yeah very cool oh yeah a little bit yeah
probably the color
yeah 60s Vibe yeah there's a lot going
on in this and it's all done really well
yeah that's all I got to say yeah it's
super nice and detailed
yeah this is a triple threat car it's a
plane a car and a submarine it just did
a triathlon
that's great it's the kind of things
that the classic James Bond movies
always had isn't it
yeah pretty much
cool stuff yeah good stuff Alex killing
it we got Kong take
next
what what
bro
this is John wicker Neo is inside oh my
God
it's ridiculous that's crazy okay but is
that new or Trinity I don't know both
it's Neo I think
why can't you just ride up a wall drive
up a wall
yeah it'd be pretty sweet I like how the
helicopter is flying sideways just like
falling down just like
yeah this one's wacky so sweet this has
the most Mayhem happening in any of
these yeah look at this city block blows
up the glass
like all those shards raining oh yeah
that looks great
and the explosion actually pushes the
cars away if you look at that oh yeah
how do we see the same things at the
same time I don't know it's crazy it's
so strange
whoa yeah that's a nice detail pushing
the cars away
dang even on the far right side like you
see those cluster of cars on the far
right they all get shifted over and then
like there's a weird matrix filter that
goes throughout the city
yeah oh yeah cool yeah that's awesome
yeah sweet good stuff good stuff
we got Shan
Anu
whoa chasing yes
so good these are those little
short-legged Japanese breed cats yeah
adorable
yeah this is cute I love the
it's just that it's so good that glass
looks so real like I feel like I can
just pick up that ball I know right it's
crazy
the water Sim inside is like you know
very subtle Sim I I think it might
honestly be like a displacement map or
something well oh for real yeah it looks
very tame in like control
dangle it looks great regardless
like a sine wave thing I see I see yeah
that's beautiful the fish is just
chilling in there yeah
I love it there's the like is the fish
powering this thing
the way the way the cats are looking at
it and that cat pursued like pray way
yeah that's
like just dead I stare honey yeah
yeah I love this one I love the colors I
love the story good concept the idea
that there's two of them also makes it
just funny or something
two kittens I love the garden outside
too the little like
yeah
good stuff shun santanu
amazing
who do we got next
joao Garcia
this is the worst I've ever been with
names guys apologies it's like a skull
character yeah
like Ghost Rider some speed is amazing
in this one I know it's so fast it's
ridiculous
I love the sky too it looks painterly
hmm yeah another one of these where not
too much detail totally works
yeah just
yeah really nice lighting just focusing
really broke red fire exhaust lighting
up the trees
with that smoke
yeah and the uh the sort of grime on the
lens when the flares come up very subtle
really sells it yeah
yeah people go heavy-handed with the
with the with the Grime on the lens but
this one's tasteful this one's well done
yeah super cool I can't wait to find a
spot in the uh in the in the top 100
Montage for this one like music does
that take you a lot of figuring out a
lot of a b testing oh my God yeah it
takes a a full-time week
full-time work week to like place them
all in the right place
dang yeah it's a lot but it's all for
the best you know
um
we got Benjamin next
I'm intrigued I like this world I love
the lighting too yeah yeah
what is that face on the front of the
car it's a little Skeleton Man this is
cool
what kind of a school it's like an
overbite full of fun cartoon eyes a
little like like a monkey skull
that's cool oh it looks like uh
Mojo Jojo
like a Mojo Jojo skull
yeah that's cool yeah yeah very cool
good volumetrics up top cool blimp in
the back good sense of scale
yeah that's interesting crazy lighting
snow looks nice yeah
like a lighting that you wouldn't that I
would never come up with like right it's
sort of feeling yeah like
yeah I've never seen light a light ring
on the inside of a tire like that like
those brake pads
but it's just like very ambient
yeah like it's it's not doing too much
and it works it feels so real even
though it's otherworldly yeah surreal
they're real dude
what that mean
[Laughter]
we gotta we got another Benjamin for you
oh man it weirdly works
yeah I love it
dude that tank coming out with the
parachutes yeah I love the design of
this thing it's super chunky and like
bulbous
feels so heavy yeah
what is that ship in the background it's
like
shredded tank
wait the what is that black ship with
the Treads oh oh
it's just fire in his little laser beam
he's shooting he's shooting his little
lasers
I just I love pausing on the first frame
of this and like go to the first frame
and pause yeah the glitch you needed to
give a little time it's just like
I see this and I'm like okay there's a
jet far in the distance here and then
like it looks like a jet coming in on
the foreground and then it's like nope
it's just tiny
boom dude he knocks him out of the way
he's like you thought this was my ship
nah son guess again
I didn't think of it like that that's
funny he's like all right guys here we
go
excuse me that's great yeah I love this
one Benjamin I love the colors the tan
and like I don't even know purple
I I don't know
it's awesome
uh next up hyung juli
oh this is a Mario level Mario
dude you nailed that run geez well I saw
that little uh that spiky ball Tower
thing oh okay I see
then Mario drifted in so I was like
this is just like so visually stunning
rainbow roads bizarre
ghost
a ghosting effect happening yeah yeah
it's pretty crazy
they're doing some like squash animation
on the
when he hits the Boost
dude this person should be doing the
Mario movie thing
this this very much so feels like the
Mario movie aesthetic like
the punchiness of the colors and yeah
it matches what the the movie trailer
for Mario movie is I love the spin out
there's a banana spin out back there
Yoshi
but he just keeps going
look at those speed lines on the front
of the cart I know they're so good
amazing
they're like following the Contour of
the cart really well
yeah I like this one a lot no notes
really yeah
good
amazing good stuff uh young yeah this is
really really sick man uh we got Nathan
for you I'm just kidding I'm just
kidding
whoa
the squishiness yeah
a lot of comic Styles in today's render
selection yeah yeah this one's just like
this one's really unique to me it's just
freaking wacky craziness
do you think there's some AI here too
I don't think so I feel it yeah
okay because usually with the AI stuff
you get like a bunch of uh temporal
artifacting like a flickering uh that
even with a ton of D flickering it still
still exists and I'm not seeing that
here at all yeah
dude look at the freaking like a lot of
Epic work yeah like the way the police
car is animated it's like
and also the car in the beginning with
the like exclamation and question mark
it's so immediately like you understand
the emotion yeah there
was that was that a Smash Bros slash
Metal Gear Solid reference that was a
Smash Bros Clint reference
there
any any random freeze frame of this I
bet looks awesome like just it's like
everything is like a comic book panel
I feel like this one out of all the
records we've seen so far doing the
comic Style Nails the the spider-verse
style the most I agree and it and it has
like its own it's it's doing that
reference but also has a voice of its
own Kinda Yeah I mean yeah I like it so
playful yeah I love it super bouncy and
all over the place
yeah super sick that's by Nathan good
stuff uh you Chen she
is next
more motorcycles oh my God
boom dude yeah those colors are sick I
love that like poster I don't even know
what that is Style
dude that car posterized yeah posterized
that car just disappears
for a tire
straight up a scrunchie that's that's a
that should go on someone's ponytail
that's funny
yeah this is like Liney I don't know how
to describe it the the energy balls on
the bottom it's like little like
connected lines looks so amazing
where yeah like on the ground where the
tires are hitting the ground those like
energy lines yeah
the orange very specific like anime
effects aesthetic Like rules being
followed yeah
oh that's so crazy yeah transformation
is always awesome
oh man just ah I love those hits
the heck is that
wait it blows up
the bridge I don't know what the heck is
that it's both like it hits the bridge
and the thing
I guess it's a missile why not oh yeah
yeah it looks a lot of hand-painted
things I think even during the
transformation
it looks like more intentional than just
kind of a cell Shader
like sometimes I think they have to do a
lot of manual work on this you think so
yeah it could be like I don't know it
just seems so
you think it's just what you see is what
you get yeah maybe it's just a very good
tuna Shader
wow yeah it's super cool oh I love the
way it breaks like that concrete that's
awesome
yeah this is awesome this is super
simple background just like it's there
there's detail but it doesn't draw your
eye yeah like just a bunch of lines on
solid color dig it
uh next one oh my goodness
that was easier than
whoa yeah
Cat Bus baby like straight it looks like
it's straight out of the movie
yeah honestly lighting and everything
colors and everything
that's beautiful very impressive
the little demonic rat lights
oh God that's awesome
dude even the way the like 2D cards are
rendered in 3D space for the trees looks
exactly Flawless like a Ghibli movie
yeah I mean I guess those weren't 3D
they were on like a multi-plane but it
looks
very similar
their background spoilers
their background is awesome too
I love the walk cycle on this guy he's
running and then he jumps and then very
casually like
got it like really the run like really
follows kind of like
2D I don't know like rules like the what
is it like animated on one like can I
see his yeah like rainbow frame yeah
because I feel like
yeah there's a little change like the
the mouths it's like
there's like a lot of 2D little
details going on yeah they're like still
like traditional motion blur happening
here and I don't know if that's helping
or working against the yeah I could have
probably worked without it
but it works either way yeah I don't
really know I didn't notice it until we
were watching framework
yeah it's awesome cool good stuff I love
it uh Nikola is next
confirm wow wow that feels so real I
know that's super realistic I know he's
going for absolute live-action realism
it feels like a commercial
this reminds me of another cinematic for
I can't remember the name of that video
game it's where you can drive all over
the country oh yeah did that ever even
come out oh yeah they made a sequel
there's there's a couple of them
I never played him uh but I know Euro
Truck Simulator that's the one
I love the color blue of this truck like
the specific truck blue it's classic man
feels great it's really nice
you know what makes it you know what's
crazy you know why it feels real
why is because there's that counter
motion blur thing going on that's
technically not correct but it is
totally what you would do if you were
copying footage or something
sure yeah
like if you had a shaky shot and you
tried to like track something in it yeah
yeah oh
yeah that's what it is it's like um like
they try to stabilize it but the motion
blur's still there
or something or something yeah
it's cool
yeah I like this one really good detail
like I saw an early version of this and
it came so so far okay it really came
along
wow
nice nice yeah
super sick
super sick Nicolas or Nicola
um we got y c
up next
cool
yeah just a beautiful render really nice
lighting yeah
he's getting out of here
let's go
I think she's like she's checking her
watch checking it yeah
she said all the time and was like let's
go it's time to speed up yeah gotta get
on the cargo train
[Music]
I love that
car animations are pink careful
attention to how the suspension should
be animated
I know
they're really doing a great job with it
um
it just feels real it that's the
toughest thing I think is animation
really at the end of the day it's
animation and if the animation is janky
you can really tell and like I'm such a
huge fan of like all these of course
that are really doing a good job with
animating their car rigs
but
I love the flickering of the light
through the train yeah same on the car
really pretty it's beautiful and it's on
the perfect spot it's like they really
are directed it nicely to
you know to to shine in the right place
super cool
yeah
YC
who's next
we got Shang Shang how well
huh sick now that's a DeLorean right oh
yeah yeah yeah who is who's the zombie
that stole it but this is some kind is
this like a is this uh Ready Player One
reference I guess or something headed to
Lorien in there yeah with your headset
and everything very tall it's like Shack
yeah goggles
No Maybe
I mean he's not wearing them as goggles
so it's hard for me to to say this looks
like just like a brain interface you
know just like
this is cool yeah the really unique
quality of the background and like the
lighting and there's film Grain on it
the it's really really nice everything
just pops out planets those planets look
like the suckers from the Candyland
Sugar Rush
what are those signs say ether dang dude
ether we are just on the same wavelength
run I don't
I don't know Aether
a here
I thought I saw a t but it yeah it just
it was curvy
oh it is ether yeah okay
also what's up with that checkerboard
texture over there on the Rock I'm
loving this like strange world yeah oh
what the heck yeah
I don't know that's weird
that's interesting but it looks
intentional as opposed to an accident it
does look intentional oh there's a yeah
there's other little Checker balls I
think it's just probably the metaverse
or something
yeah yeah this is definitely the
metaverse
I'm gonna look at the planets they look
so like
like smoothly sanded wood like creamy
yeah this one's cool very good render
quality very good lighting nice
um who's next Matt
I got you Matt a boom Oh wait hold on
yeah I messed up oh my face hold on I
think that is
not I had a nightmare like this there we
go there we go my bad
boom dip in the background it's got a
mouth
dude the sand looks so good yeah yeah
the background where the
worm is like crashing like a whale thing
oh wow the the like uh the sand around
it when it crashes down is so well done
whoa
dude
so much going on on that ship I know I'm
transfixed
I love how it just like it boosts away
she's like
yeah dang that is nice
love this so many crazy simulations yeah
you could watch this one for a while I
know I love that whale dude that is
creepy oh so the whale
is actually organic you can see the back
of it is organic and all like all dry
well it's like a robot face it's a
helmet on him yeah
it's like General breathing
interesting oh there's like some weird
animation happening above the whale's
head like on its head you can see just a
little bit
oh some gears something yeah
cool design really cool design that's
really cool
heck yeah good stuff Matt also this
looks straight out of the like out of
Star Wars like they're shooting along uh
not Tatooine but the
Jabbar to do whatever the name of the oh
[Laughter]
it's like hey where do you want this all
this brand new Star Wars movie to be set
not tattooing right and they're like oh
no no another boring desert planet
Good Times
sorry no all good all good no all good
all good all good I only know one Star
Wars desert Planet that's all
Tomas Thomas dishes dude look at this
thing
that's great freaking roly-poly
that's beautiful
one wheel yes the animal called that
does this armadillo armadillo armadillo
yeah armadillo mobile
yeah it's like if this was if Batman
wasn't a wheel was an armadillo man
it's got the Gatling gun dude same time
so many times
Get Out of My Head Right your your
brains are like the same Os Os and
similar stats
uh yeah good lighting I like it like
Sunset Vibes yeah like
I feel nice
yeah sweet I love it I love it
so this is how all satellite dishes of
this kind actually look now
um
just use the graveyard satellite dish
graveyard that'd be crazy
um sweet Thomas Tomas we got Ang
not Ang Lee but Ang Liu
oh yeah
that's sweet yeah this one is freaking
crazy the the lighting the just the
color palette is great the color palette
the render quality is
ridiculous
animation's a little tough I'm a horse
you know it's like I feel like you're
being held back like the horse being
held back or something a little bit
but when it breaks through the force
field at the end yes
boost but yeah this is this is
ridiculous the render quality on this is
insane
and a good sense of depth too like
there's enough stuff scattered
throughout the field that the camera
motion really looks nice
yeah
those smoke Sims man what the heck
beautiful oh
being ridiculous
beautiful very beautiful and Lou
congratulations top 100 very nice all
right we got uh Alex up next
whoa
someone had to do it that's cool that's
nice
okay he's going from the exact same spot
he's going from yeah 19 uh 1955 to 1855
as per part three uh yeah like
nice that's cool very cool but it's the
exact yeah exact same area this is great
it is the same area honestly look at the
look at the silhouette uh background
silhouette that's amazing very cool it's
not the thing they're doing also is like
the it looks like the movies like film
stock and everything yeah and the
lighting it's very nice the way it blows
out in that second second bit like it
just looks so real it looks like footage
it's ridiculous
so it blows out and then like yeah look
at the smoke Optical effect yeah like
that little flash is like a old school
Optical
thing very nice so good like that's
gorgeous photo real man insane I love it
that one's really good I like it yeah
yeah
awesome really nice good work Alex it's
tough to get a DeLorean in here because
I guys there were so many DeLoreans and
so many DeLorean Defenders oh my
goodness a good go-to yeah
um but
Alex you did a good job with it really
nice
love it
okay
Marco
let's see what you got
whoa
cool Camaro
that's what bumblebee does in the first
Transformers movie transforms from an
old Camaro to a new Camaro
the only my only gripe about this is I
wish it would have transformed into a
new color to like tell that it is
transforming yeah yeah but
this is amazing I love it just like also
like he's gonna become a robot oh okay
another kind of car
I love the that looks is this like
Chicago under the God dang it Ren our
minds I was gonna say is underneath the
train thing like he got it looks like
New York to me
it'd be Brooklyn
yeah
or or no Manhattan
I love it yeah so beefy
that's good so nice like the sense of
speed here is done really nicely mm-hmm
all the particles and debris whipping by
yeah helps that out a lot
great yeah
super sick all right gentlemen
the the chat is caught up they know
what's going on because they know
there's only one left
um yeah yeah
absolutely so we're gonna watch this
last one and then we're going to
announce the top five
um now this last one we just got a roast
we got a roast oh yeah yeah for sure for
sure here I pent up all this
Halo Recon
Leandro
this is very cool I love it
great cool I love the design of that
bike yeah
so does the bike become his armor oh
yeah yeah it looks like it absorbs
that's so cool dude
first I should have thought this was a
Halo armor like a Halo Master Chief
armor at first because yeah I see it's
not but for a moment I love that little
smooth robot dude in the back though
he tries to catch him with his two hands
like so from so far away he's like he
only has another guy so the depth
perception is not that good oh true true
here I want to see this transition
dude that frame this this is so sick
that lean in like that ah
all right let's see so he Dodges he
Dodges some real irresponsibly placed
bricks like oof
but here let's see this transformation
she comes there there's some caution
okay so the lights turn off
looks like
the right
left side of the wheel comes up
the wheel comes up and in
oh he ditches oh he ditches his pack
there's stuff on the back he ditches it
okay and then the wheels come up to his
back
dude that's so cool that's sweet yeah
that must have been really hard to
design in real life I know for it to
snap on you
and three frames look at the okay so
look at the um front wheel the armor
like lights up
you see the front wheel how it has those
little plates clasping the front wheel
it becomes his like forearms his
gauntlets
oh so yeah
in front of him was just regular metal
early on and now it becomes emissive oh
so cool
yeah that's a cool design I like it I do
too that's really fun
amazing Leandro good stuff good stuff
yay we did it top 100.
oh
boy oh boy I wonder how long it took to
to render all of the top 100
collectively I have that data too
oh yeah
here let me find out really quick
um
let's see
foreign
oh no
hey you guys you guys are back
all right let me see let me add up
ran you have to help me with some math
here okay
okay
all right how many pro how many hours
did your scene take to render let's
tally up
all of this
data
I'm gonna peek into his monitor
what is he calculating there all right
let's see what is it equals the sum
of
parentheses first cell slide to the last
cell okay close parentheses
[Music]
[Laughter]
what's going on who's not listening I'm
so sorry I was distracted oh they
distracted me
it's not my fault
97 and a half days wow wow wow that's it
that's how long it takes me on my
computer to render anything wait really
I mean that kind of makes sense that
really averages out to just slightly
less than an hour per sorry slightly
less than a day's worth of rendering for
every five second shot so that's that's
a lot of rendering time here it's like
20 hours let's look at 20 hours per shot
the
the total work time
let's see
that's
I've got a 43 hour render going right
now oh
wow satisfying render huh oh I need to
do that yeah Peter you do it's due
Friday
300.50 I mean thousand hours
wow
wait say the number one hours 356
000 hours
is that right I feel like it's not 356
000 hours and days
14 833 days in years
that is 40 years what
holy okay 40 years
time
oh my god dude I I'm not even that old
yet
oh man me too yeah that's oh yeah that's
so long
laughs
oh boy
all right gentlemen do we do we want to
take
um like a three minute break and then
announce top five or do we just want to
announce the top five let's do it let's
just do it all right let's do good let
me let me like get my stuff right let me
make sure this makes sense we're gonna
start with number five right as opposed
to starting with number one yes it's
been a long time since I've said like
what people are winning so let me just
make sure I'm getting this right
um
appreciation
hold on let me let me do this right I
don't want to mess this up this would be
bad
hold on
bear with me chat thank you
hey I'm gonna look at the chat
okay I'm scared to touch anything so I
don't disconnect
okay okay
all right so
place is going to receive
um
a oh by the way but by the way
every render we just saw you guys get a
free kit bash 3D kit and a free t-shirt
code from caft
um so everyone in this top 100 thanks
just won something so congratulations to
everyone who did this
um for who participated and I will
mention this before we announce the
winners I'm just gonna say
that uh once again
thank you to everyone who submitted uh
for all the incredible work I mean we
just heard it here four decades worth of
work was poured into this 4 200
individual renders
um you guys knocked it out you had a
good time with it and uh I I couldn't be
more excited about the incredible work
that that has been put out this is a
very special one because it's different
from anything that we've done in the
past and uh I really I can't wait to to
set it to some music Casey Edwards he's
working on the music right now
um it's sounding amazing and top 100 I
believe comes out the top 100 Montage I
believe comes out next week
um so definitely yeah definitely uh
check that out so
um but yes top 100 you all got a kit
bash 3D kit of choice and uh a caft
t-shirt code so any t-shirt on cath.com
though they'll get you
um but for fifth place all right you
guys would get 200 bucks to caft uh
towards calf.com get they do a bunch of
really awesome designs lots of cool
clothes beanies hats
um jackets sweatpants uh socks they have
everything bags even
they're a Turkish design brand really
cool
um you also get three kit bash 3D kits
of your choice
um anything on their site uh is is is
yours uh you can pick three of those and
then you also get a Max on one year-long
subscription so that includes Cinema 4D
red the red giant Suite uh Universe
forger and zbrush as well
um so it's not just for people who use
c4d there's lots of other stuff that
comes with it
um so that is going to be both fifth
place and fourth place so without
further Ado let me just make sure
that we are on
the art screen so you guys can see the
art here
all right
so
fifth place
it's not this it's not this one
it's not this one it's not this one it's
always heart-wrenching what are you
doing this moment
every time but it's this one
Sam Haughton Fifth Place coming in real
nice yeah
yeah serious man serious
um love the more spaceships panels with
Fabrics everybody that's the lesson here
right if you want to win next time just
cover this bishop of fabric and
and you know what and GG yeah for sure
for sure
um yeah this this one's incredible the
the lighting on it the animation the
story The visceral nature of it um it's
super intense all the smoke in the
background you really coming together
with it this render came a long way
um from from the beginning so loving it
so much congratulations Sam seriously
man that's freaking awesome
hell yeah
good stuff yeah
um fourth place fourth place fourth
place so fourth place gets all the same
stuff you guys get 200 bucks towards
caft it's not this one it's not this one
it's not this one
hide your screen and then bring it up
it's not this one switch back to the
four of us and then switch back Edge I
love you I love you freaking out
everyone right now it's not this one but
it'll be the next one no no but it'll be
the next one okay it'll be the next one
okay
um
so uh
uh what was I even saying
fourth place congratulations wins the
same things
congratulations this is David milor
um wonderful work man wonderful work
it's so unique very fun it's just ah
it's so beautiful so colorful it is like
candy for my soul for my eyeballs
um yeah it's like giving candy to a baby
like donuts and donuts not taking candy
from people but giving it oh beautiful
wonderful mix of styles Wonder wonderful
aesthetic wonderful colors wonderful
textures animation just everything man
uh David malore man congratulations to
you congrats yeah yeah
all right wait okay we're at Clint Clint
I'm gonna do it right this time okay yes
yes
there you go there you go thank you
thank you thank you thank you
before we continue shout out to all of
the top 100 they are all incredible when
when we were like deciding on these top
five like I straight up said this like
even if I wanted to get into the top 100
and tried to I really don't think I
could so I'm just gonna judge him
instead yeah
his name
yeah I know agreed I know it's tough you
know a lot of you guys are like really
you want to win you're trying to win
trying to go for that win trying to go
for that top 100.
um and I think it's a of course yeah of
course you know it is it is a challenge
right at the end of the day
um but don't let it get you down you
know it's it's such a small number of
people
you know make the top 100 and even a
smaller number make the top five so it's
okay it's as long as you guys are having
fun and as long as you guys are learning
and we're having a good time together
that's that's really the point so yeah
um but in third place all right we got
third place you're getting some Rococo
smart gloves right so you get all the
hand animation all that good stuff
um and we also got 200 bucks towards
caft.com get yourself some nice uh nice
shirts nice pants nice jackets some bags
you decked out and then of course you
get the three kit bash 3D kits of your
choice
um anything from their website and then
um as well as the Max on one year-long
subscription which includes c4d red
giant sweet Universe forger and zbrush
so it's quite a lot quite a lot of
things
it's a deal indeed and without further
ado
Donald sella
yeah I love this one so much so it's so
cool yeah this is so fancy freaking
beautiful
oh so much happening the explosions the
way it like Puffs out oh
yeah stage explosions
great yeah it's a movie I think we'd all
watch oh absolutely happily yeah
that'll be sick for sure yeah
congratulations Donald congratulations
to this person well deserved well well
deserved all right
second place second place
um is getting let me cue it up first
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes I can see
all the awards right here they're just
off camera and they're amazing
so many you know I can touch them
um second place you're getting a full-on
Rococo smartsuit Pro 2.
um yeah the full-on the full-on deal the
full suit
um as well as the 200 calf prize the
three kit bash 3D kits of your choice
and the Maxon one year-long subscription
I keep hearing you say 200 cash prize I
know right yeah it sounds like that for
sure cafs.com prize
um
and without further Ado we got our boy
Lee
petrol yeah yeah the freaking giblet
fish yes
momentum pupils I want to protect him
with my life
oh so good I think if he gets kicked in
the back it's like getting kicked in the
balls that could be very true yeah into
all six of them
this is to me this is like the most
unique render of all of them
very cool
amazing good stuff Lee congratulations
on second place
yeah and uh
first place baby first place let's
figure it out
all right all right how's everyone doing
status check on everyone Peter you alive
Ren great oh I'm I'm relaxed man I'm
chilling super hard five I'm on the
contrary over stimulated yeah it's
controlling me
oh they're amazing amazing
what's going on over there
we're just being fools be quiet down
there Clint sorry
all right guys you ready this is it this
is it okay
final number one Ultra Mega final for
real Ultimate final first place
is getting all the things I mentioned
uh the 200 calfs.com prize uh the three
kit bash 3D kits of choice Max on one
year-long subscription they're also
getting I do not want to get this wrong
let me double check grand prize
grand prize
100 dollars
they're also getting a full performance
capture bundle from Rococo that comes
with the gloves that comes with the
facial cap with the suit maxing it out
um and freaking and we're also I'm gonna
fly you down to Colorado for camp
mograph this year so I'll see you there
it's gonna be a good time
I mean so
it lives in Colorado already
I don't know I have no idea I made that
I believe it'll be clear we have drum
roll our first place
from all the way hailing from Brazil
we got fabri CEO
with yes the bug boy
congratulations man congrats
this one is awesome it is freaking
10 out of 10 ultimate Max the lighting
the quality the animation the colors the
story The composing with I mean
composing the film green it's just oh
geez man the full package yeah
I don't know if you need do you need a
visa
like hope you hopefully your passport's
all set up because you're coming to the
US right now yes let's let's Google this
September 15th I believe September 14th
no I'll call the post office I'll see
you'll put a good word in the post
office
they could
they could uh you know package the
person just send them through mail it's
a good way to uh
oh congratulations guys seriously that
awesome congrats
another great challenge another top five
another amazing 100. um guys Alan uh
freaking what are you guys
Peter Ren
I am like maxed out I've hit my my
stream limit how you guys we've been
going for five hours almost wow I could
do another five hours easy stop because
I barely did anything at least since our
Flagship started not since the stream
but yeah here we go
no this is this has been a lot of fun
that's my first time on one of these and
I really had a lot of fun and I was very
overstimulated by all this amazing
amazing Artistry and skill
yeah
this is amazing yeah
they're inspiring it's like
intimidatingly inspiring it's like wow
so many people are capable of this
incredible stuff I gotta step up my game
seriously and I want to participate in
the next one like you think you're
better than me I could do this too
someday somehow we should all submit
under Anonymous names
down yes yeah Ransom at one time you and
Jordan submitted that was cool the first
one yeah yeah that's awesome
um but yeah guys thank you we've we've
been going for a long time I'm gonna let
you I'm gonna let you guys go chat I'll
I'll hang out with you for another like
10 minutes um we'll do a little BRB and
I'll come back and hang out with you
guys for a little bit but uh Alan Peter
Ren guys thank you so freaking much you
guys are the best thank you for making
that thanks for having you yeah thanks
for having me absolutely love y'all have
a good one
no no no
laughs
[Music]
foreign
oh man that was intense guys
what a what a day
like I feel like every six months you
know it always boils down to this to
this day
um
and it's always exhilarating it's always
you know it's terrifying at the same
time too you know because I like I hope
you know me and the moderators we go
through and we choose the top 100 very
carefully
um and I always hope that it's a good
representation of of all the art that
came through and I know it is at the end
of the day I know it is and of course
it's like it's terrifying it's a lot of
pressure to pick five winners
um it's really hard it is really really
hard because there are so many great
renders out there
um there was a couple renders that that
came so close but they you guys they
delivered them late
and that that is that was gut-wrenching
for me that hurts so bad but I you know
you can't I can't you can't the late
renders they'll make the all renders
Montage
um for sure I'll get you guys on that
um that's okay
but uh yeah can't can't do top 100 if uh
if you're late unfortunately
but you know it's it's tough I really
hope you guys learned a lot throughout
throughout this time I'm looking at the
chat here I see you guys in the chat let
me let me pop this up hang out with you
guys for a little bit just for like
another 10 minutes
um Edge dude Edge Edge dude your render
was so good your render was so freaking
good oh my God absolutely absolutely
incredible man
um it sucks because I I've really come
to know a lot of you guys through these
challenges and I just I want everyone to
win I really really want everyone to win
and um it hurts it hurts when you know I
want to just give prizes I guess we did
top 100 right but
even some of you guys like
who who who barely made the top 100 so
close so close made
under um
it's tough especially when I when I know
you guys and have have a relationship
with you guys over
um you know or Discord you know so
yeah I hope everyone is doing okay after
all that I hope we got some thumbs ups
and some smiley faces all around for you
guys
um and I hope you all learned a lot
throughout this and and had a good time
with it
um but man that was awesome it was super
cool to get uh the captain
for this one
I I've been a fan of his forever for a
long time and he's just the all-around
chill dude it's super super cool
um and of course to have Ren and Peter
back on as well it's always a good time
I love those guys so much
um
yeah guerne yes Billy yeah man you had a
lot of fun participating for the first
time
um congrats on top 100 that's awesome
super super cool
[Music]
um
yeah if you guys have any questions for
me please feel free to at Punisher me
here in the chat
um if you guys want to support more
challenges like this one of the best
things you can do is
um is pick up a sticker sheet it's a
limited edition endless engines sticker
sheet especially if you participated in
the challenge
um get you some stickers they're in
they're linked Below in the description
here
um
go pick some up they're on my print
store
um we're fulfilling through printful so
we're I'm keeping shipping costs pretty
darn low for everyone across the world
um yeah they're super cool I got some
right here actually
foreign
yeah
boom
yeah nice little sticker sheet and then
it even has like little cars and and uh
little motorcycles and stuff here like
as the background and
two different colors for you guys you
have a bunch of stickers you can put
them on your water bottle like got mine
chilling here
and I think there's like an ee around
here somewhere
yeah chilling right here
um so yeah definitely go pick up some
stickers
um like limited edition collectible run
and it really helps support more
challenges like this because
you know it's
it's a lot it's a lot
a lot to set these things up so I
appreciate you guys very very much
otherwise if you just enjoyed the video
and enjoyed hanging out that's all good
too no worries all right so I'm looking
um at the questions what's what's the
next challenge no idea no idea we'll
figure that one out
um
when is the next challenge it's gonna be
in August the next challenge will be in
August so I'll be letting you guys know
kind of like as we get closer I'll keep
I'll be keeping you posted if you want
to know when the next challenge is I
tried to like set up an email thing I
know a lot of you guys who submitted you
were like um yes send me emails but when
I went to actually go like set up this
massive thousand multi thousand person
email list
um I didn't quite understand how
involved it was so I need to do a little
bit more research on that but hopefully
this next challenge I can do a big email
blast to you guys hopefully not trying
to spam you all just trying to let you
guys know when the next challenge is but
the Discord server is a great way of
course subscribing to this channel if
you're not subscribed already please
subscribe hit the little bell
um icon for notifications that way when
I do come out with another announcement
video in August you guys will know
when it's challenge time we do them
every six months so in the meantime if
you guys want to challenge yourself
there's also the Discord server that is
linked below you'll just need to scroll
a little bit further down in the
description but um yeah we do weekly
challenges I think we're doing a weekly
challenge this week already so you know
if you're ready to dive in
weekly challenges on the Discord service
how we do it uh we judge them every
single week too so it's a good time
um do you think I can use a laptop for
blender yes uh what is a
any okay a lot of you guys have this
question any any chance for critique or
feedback for non-winners
um a hundred percent yes 100 here's what
I'm thinking obviously I can't go
through and give feedback for every
single one because there's 4 200 of them
and I would I would be in my grave
um with my voice just like my voice box
ripped out it'd be too much what I do
want to do is I want to go through
um
uh I don't know if it's gonna be this
Monday or next Monday
because I'm just kind of making this up
off the top of my head
but just be on the Discord okay be on
the Discord and I'm gonna hit up
um I'm gonna hit up you guys on the
endless engines announcement and I'm
gonna say hey we're gonna do uh a little
live review and I think what we can do
is just have y'all submit like we've
done we did these like weekly chats
every Monday on the Discord server and
I'm just gonna pull up a render and talk
about it for a minute or two and um just
kind of give my thought process it will
be a critique it will be feedback so
you just know that it's gonna be like
hey this part's lacking this could have
been better it would have been cool to
have this so really try and come at it
from a educational perspective and of
course I'll do my best I'm not gonna say
this is garbage whatever whatever I'm
really gonna try and help you know give
you guys some positive feedback so I
would love to do that maybe this Monday
at uh at noon might be the best time to
do that it's when we've done our Discord
Hangouts for the endless engines
challenge in the past so
keep your eyes peeled on the Discord
look in the events okay I'll put an
event there and we'll uh I'll do an hour
with you guys I think that would be cool
um at at noon Pacific Standard Time
Rick no nick nick Roy
um thank you for the Super Chat thanks
for all other super chats I missed
during this thing I know it was a lot
but he says thanks again for doing this
I'm just learning better it was my first
challenge I learned a lot I appreciate
you absolutely man I'm glad you learned
stuff that's the whole point
we're just having fun with it guys we're
having fun with it don't let the fact
that you maybe not didn't make top 100
or you didn't get top five get you down
okay don't
don't do that to yourself guys come on
have fun with it keep the fun times
going
um we got a lot of questions here let's
see
how long did it take me to go through
all of it
uh like three working days
three full working days just about
um so a long time
okay
um what happened to the renders in my
Instagram post one oh wondrous yes yes I
see you I see you I see you
um those were as you guys know not top
100 three of them were were late renders
and the others were just renders that
almost made top 100 that I really loved
um and wanted to include
in this process and and in this like you
know
public side of things
as much as I possibly could because like
I said at the end of the day there's a
lot of renders that I love that that you
know
that should be shown you know so
yeah wondrous apologies man if I like I
don't want to get anyone's hopes up I
I'm sorry if I uh if I like if I did
that but um
yeah man
good stuff good stuff
let's see
David yes my Lord yes you got fourth
place dude yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
congrats man congrats you nailed it you
freaking nailed it I wanted I wanted to
tell everyone beforehand but I had to
keep it
yeah I had to keep it uh keep it here
um
can you show can I show you guys the
render I made for the challenge I didn't
really make renders for the challenge I
spent so much of my time was spent
um producing the challenge I made a
couple renders for an intro title card
that you guys will see uh on uh uh well
here let me just show you it's rough
it's not really polished or anything
think the only way I can show you guys
is by switching
this screen
so I just have this like
there'll be like text over this you know
titles and whatnot
I have some temp this is like temp uh
temp stuff
that I have for timing
obviously I got to adjust the numbers
adjust the font stuff but that's that
and then I have this like
this one I'm not the biggest fan of it
it's a little crazy
um so I'm probably gonna
try and clean this up or maybe even not
even use that one and then I have
another one
let's see uh
Huts lost in here but it's like of a
motorcycle helmet thing
where I use Rococo video to like track
my head movement and then I have like
the reflections of the city in a
motorcycle helmet so I'm still working
on all that stuff you know
um
yeah so I'm still working on it I I just
hadn't had time uh to really do a
full-on render I wanted to but
it is what it is
what else I'll hang out with you guys
for a little bit more and then I should
get some food
yeah I mean top 100 is very difficult
it's it's a really really intense
process and
um
yeah there was there was a there could
have been a top 250 you know what I'm
saying it's it's nuts
um
am I going to reopen the submission link
or the complete montage
uh do you mean no no the submission
submissions are closed but
um I will have a a place where like
people can see people's uh social media
and whatnot so they when they are
watching the full render full Montage
then they can like click on the artists
that they like and follow them
can you have any information what
rendering engine the winners used I
don't know I don't know
um we're going to link them in the
Discord
uh in a you know in the next next couple
days here
um so you know maybe you can reach out
to them or something
um
what else what other questions we got
yeah I mean I just really really
appreciate you guys
taking the time and
having a good mindset with all of this
stuff
uh it was really fun it was fun to do a
montage that it was different the last
ones have just been people you know we
of course we did Dynamic machines but
this one is the highest energy and I
can't wait so next weekend guys is the
top 100 Montage with custom music from
Casey Edwards that's gonna be on the
25th all right this upcoming Saturday
and the following Saturday is going to
be the all renders Montage which I think
is going to be like six something hours
it's gonna be ridiculous
um
and uh
and then yeah after that there's going
to be an art breakdown uh two weeks
after that so I'm gonna get into like
how I created the title card stuff so
I'm still working on that but um yeah
I'll give you guys a little BTS on that
process
do I know how many submissions came from
Kuwait
yeah
hold on
standby
let's see
foreign
s came from Kuwait
crazy
yeah it's nuts I mean we had submissions
from all over the world multiple like we
had we had from Africa
we had from all over Asia North America
South America I don't think we got
Antarctica
uh I don't think so
um these are these are windows yeah
these are windows
um but uh yeah it was it was cool how
many from Israel let's find out we had
some from Ukraine too which is crazy
um Israel we had
let me sort here sort by
one moment
find out how many
records we got from Israel
28 renders from Israel 28 from Israel
super cool
from Kenya let's see how many how many
vendors from Kenya
17 renders from Kenya
pretty freaking awesome I love it
yeah uh Belgium you want to know Belgium
Belgium
Belgium renders
uh 28 28 as well 28 Belgium renders
throw down your guys's country let's
find out Greenland
Zero from Greenland unless I'm spelling
that wrong how could I be spelling that
wrong
what about Iceland
I feel like that's wrong though I feel
like you gotta have some agreement
we had two two from Iceland
India dude India India prevailed
see we got a lot from India
381 renders from India freaking awesome
Argentina you got some love in here
origin Tina
I was 19 renders North Korea dude I
don't think North Korea
yeah zero renders from North Korea
absolutely not
Singapore
we got 20 renders from Singapore
from Jordan how many rooms we have from
Jordan 11 renders from Jordan that's
pretty crazy
uh New Zealand let's see let's see New
Zealand
36 Runners from New Zealand
Colombia
Colombia we got eight renders from
Colombia Czech Republic
33 from the Czech Republic that's pretty
nice Nigeria
26 renters from Nigeria dude freaking
sick
love it love it
South Africa we got 45 vendors from
South Africa
this is awesome this is so freaking cool
like all over the world we got renders
from you guys like
that's awesome worldwide man
Ukraine
31 renders from Ukraine that is nuts
that is freaking nuts man
Ethiopia
17 renders from Ethiopia
dude that's so cool
so cool Egypt
where you at Egypt 16 renders we got
16 renders from Egypt Brazil are our
number one is from Brazil
um
but we got 53 renders from Brazil
I know right it's crazy Italy Talia
uh 55 range from Italy
yep
turkey I know we got some Turkish
renders
we got 43 renders from Turkey freaking
awesome
Algeria all right let's Algeria
10 renders from Algeria I don't even
know where that is
freaking awesome
Philippines
these Philip Philippines
wow I can't spell
30 renders from the Philippines we got
yeah we got 19 from Greece we got 167
from France
we got uh 15 from South Korea
15 from Japan
Tunisia Tunisia I've even heard of that
country but we got one
and it's probably you
I love it Finland
24 minutes from Finland guys the list
goes on and on and on
that's freaking awesome
geez
I'm starving
I'm going to a friend's birthday in an
hour and a half so I should probably go
and get some food guys
but thank you for your time thank you
for your patience thank you thanks for
hanging out with me
um if you bought a sticker
thank you for the support it means a lot
if you want to buy stickers i've got a
link in the description endless engine
stickers get them all you can limited
edition especially if you participated
it's a nice little keepsake
to take with you
um so thank you guys
it's pretty nuts to uh to wrap up
another one like this so next week I
look forward to the weekly challenge
but I'll play you out
with the native flute let's let's see
how this goes
foreign
[Music]